Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe Nummer 44 unserer Gesprächsreihe über Forschung, über Lehre, über auch das Wissen. Und selbiges zu erringen und selbiges zu erhalten und dieses erhaltene Wissen auch wieder in die Welt zu bringen, das ist das Thema heute. Wir wollen uns unterhalten über Bibliotheken und ganz besonders wollen wir uns unterhalten über die Herausforderungen des digitalen Zeitalters für diese ehrwürdigen Institutionen und könnte mir keinen besseren Gesprächspartner vorstellen für dieses Thema als Ralf Stockmann, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo Ralf, wir kennen uns auch schon sehr lange. Trotzdem habe ich das Gefühl, haben wir uns eigentlich über dieses Thema immer nur so am Rande ausgetauscht, was natürlich für so ein Gespräch auch ganz vorteilhaft ist, weil jetzt können wir uns mal endlich alles erzählen.
Ich habe immer gesagt, Metadaten, du brauchst mehr Metadaten.
Ja, dem habe ich nie widersprochen. Da liegen wir auf der gleichen Linie. Aber vielleicht mal zu dir, du bist beschäftigt bei der Staatsbibliothek zu Berlin, wie es so schön heißt.
Stiftung preußischer Kulturbesitz, um den ganzen Titel drin zu haben.
Jawoll, wir lassen hier nichts aus, auch nicht, dass du Referatsleiter bist im Bereich Innovationsmanagement, Onlinebibliotheksdienstleistungen. Richtig zusammengefasst?
Ja.
Genau, und da postulierst du auch eine umfangreiche Agenda. Aber vielleicht magst du das mal selber zusammenfassen, was dein Aufgabengebiet aus deiner Perspektive dort eigentlich ist.
Ja, also es sind eigentlich zwei Komponenten. Das eine ist Innovationsmanagement und das andere sind halt diese Onlinerepräsentanz von Wissen und von Informationen und halt alles, was irgendwo die Staatsbibliothek online bringt. Und beim Innovationsmanagement bei der Komponente ist dann eher so die Frage, wie geht man eigentlich mit der Herausforderung um, dass sich Bibliotheken jetzt eigentlich tagtäglich neu erfinden und wandeln müssen und wie kann man solche Innovationsprozesse in Bibliotheken eigentlich angehen. Wenn man jetzt so ein Schlagwort hat wie digitale Transformation, dann könnte man ja auf den Gedanken kommen, naja jetzt wird alles mal einmal irgendwie digital umgestellt und dann ist es digital und dann kann man das Thema aber auch abschließen. Und so ist es aber nicht, sondern wenn an irgendwas fertig hat, dann ist es eigentlich in der Sekunde ja schon wieder veraltet und man muss sich schon wieder die nächste Innovation einfallen lassen und schon wieder schauen, was ist das nächste Themengebiet, was irgendwo angerollt kommt.
Das heißt dieser Teil meines Referats geht eher in die Richtung, wie kann man eine Gesamtstruktur eigentlich aufbauen, die ständig innovativ ist oder die ständig sich überhaupt an die Gegebenheiten anpassen kann.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie mit der Diskussion um Sicherheit, das ist auch kein Zustand, sondern ein Prozess, wie man so schön sagt, und so siehst du das auch für die digitale Arbeit?
Eindeutig ja. Und die zweite Komponente fragt dann halt wirklich, okay es geht nicht nur darum, jetzt Dinge einfach irgendwie digital zu bringen, die wir als Bibliothek anbieten, sei es jetzt irgendwie unser ganz klassischer Sammlungsbestand oder seien es jetzt Datenbanken oder seien es andere Wissensressourcen, sondern eben auch immer wieder die Frage zu stellen, wie tun wir das eigentlich und tun wir das zeitig und tun wir das so, dass andere Wissenschaftler damit wirklich was vernünftig anfangen können.
Sag doch nochmal was zur Staatsbibliothek als solche, wie die Staatsbibliothek jetzt eigentlich also Organisation aufgehängt ist in Deutschland? Welche Rolle spielt die Staatsbibliothek für andere Bibliotheken? Ist das so eine Art Überbibliothek, wo es ein paar Bücher gibt, die es sonst nirgendwo gibt oder?
Das hat ja fast jede Bibliothek. Also vom Bestand her ist es so, dass wir sicherlich eine der größten Universalbibliotheken sind. Also Universalbibliothek meint immer vom Begriff her, man sammelt eigentlich über alle Fachbereiche, nichts desto trotz haben wir natürlich auch ein paar Schwerpunkte, beispielsweise in den Sozialwissenschaften. Und was uns sicherlich auszeichnet sind die sogenannten Sonderabteilungen, die man bei uns hat. Also das ist beispielsweise die Orientabteilung oder die Musikabteilung, in der wir also wirklich beispielsweise ganz spektakuläre Autografen haben. Also ich hatte beispielsweise schon das Original von Beethovens 9. in der Hand. Also wirklich, wo Beethoven selber mit Federkiel halt entsprechend die Sachen geschrieben hat. Oder die Zauberflöte hatte ich im Original in der Hand. Das ist dann schon ganz nett, wenn man da mal so in den Hochsicherheitstrakt hinabsteigen kann...
In diesen heiligen Hallen. Sehr passend.
... der Aura des Originals verfallen kann. Und das sind dann natürlich wirkliche Unikatbestände halt, die es so halt nirgendwo anders auf der Welt gibt. Und davon hat die Staatsbibliothek natürlich schon so einiges. Aber wir haben auch sagen wir mal als ganz normale Wissenschaftsbibliothek natürlich auch so Standardwerke für den juristischen Bereich und dann halt auch viel an Onlinedatenbanken, e-Journals, das ganze Spektrum.
Also zum Verständnis, es handelt sich schon auch um eine Bibliothek mit einem öffentlichen Bereich, wo man hingehen kann und sich einfach mal ein Buch aus dem Regal holen kann?
Absolut, wir haben sogar zwei oder drei öffentliche Bereiche. Also die Geschichte der Staatsbibliothek ist insofern etwas durchaus interessant, als dass wir ja durch die deutsche Teilung auch die Bibliothek geteilt worden ist. Das heißt also, wir haben jetzt zwei große Standorte in Berlin. Das eine ist Potsdamer Straße, das ist da wo ich sitze. Das war früher wirklich mit Blick auf die Mauer. Das war ja totales Niemandsland und dann stand da quasi die Stabi und man schaute aufs nichts. Das war allerdings lange vor meiner Zeit. Und der zweite Standort war halt unter den Linden oder ist es jetzt auch immer noch. Das war halt dann die Oststaatsbibliothek. Und dann nach der Wiedervereinigung war so eine der großen Herausforderungen, wie man dann auch diese beiden Bibliothekssysteme eigentlich wieder harmonisiert.
Weil sie sich natürlich unterschiedlich entwickelt haben zwangsläufig.
Ganz genau, unterschiedliche Kataloge, unterschiedliche Standards durchaus in Teilen. Und das ist ein Prozess, der auch heute noch nicht vollständig abgeschlossen ist. Dann gibt es noch einen dritten Standort im Westhafen, der ist im Norden, da ist beispielsweise unsere Kinder- und Jugendbuchabteilung drin, mit auch sehr sehr speziellen und tollen Beständen. Das ist dann etwas weiter draußen, aber das lohnt auch auf jeden Fall mal eine Reise, sich das mal anzugucken. Aber da haben wir also dann wirklich spektakuläre Lesesäle. Ich finde mir persönlich der schönere ist dann schon noch der Potsdamer Straße. Was aber mit einem Film zu tun hat, nämlich von Wim Wenders, der Himmel über Berlin. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den so vor Augen hast.
Nicht in allen Facetten, aber ich lasse mich jetzt mal wieder eintauchen.
Da gibt es so im ersten Drittel diese sehr elegischen Steadycam-Sequenzen. Das heißt also die Kamera, die so sehr schwebend aufgehängt ist und wo man gar kein Bildwackeln hat. Und da hat fährt die Kamera durch die Staatsbibliothek und auf der Tonspur von dem Film hört man, was die Leute denken, während sie in der Staatsbibliothek sitzen und irgendwie einen Text lesen. Das ist so eine sehr ätherische Atmosphäre, die Wim Wenders da hergestellt hat. Und ich hatte völlig vergessen, dass das in der Stabi in Berlin gedreht worden ist. Und so an einem meiner ersten Arbeitstage, als ich so durch den Lesesaal laufe, denke ich, verdammt das kennst du doch hier. Ist das nicht eigentlich hier das, wo Himmel über Berlin spielt? Und dann habe ich mir das nochmal angeguckt und dachte, verdammt das ist es wirklich. Dann habe ich mich irgendwann mal nach Dienstschluss mal hingestellt und bin dann mal mit meiner eigenen Kamera nochmal genau die Bahn abgelaufen, die Wim Wenders damals abgefilmt hat und habe da mal so ein A-B YouTube-Video gemacht, wie es also dann irgendwie 25 Jahre später quasi eigentlich genau dieselbe Ecke aussieht.
Musste ich aber wieder runternehmen, weil Wim Wenders und seine Erben davon not amused waren. Obwohl der Originalfilm auf YouTube steht lustigerweise. Aber meine künstlerische Collage musste runter, Urheberrecht halt, muss überwunden werden.
Ja das werden wir sicherlich vielleicht auch nochmal am Rande anstoßen.
Ja, aber toller Lesesaal. Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Also Staatsbibliothek ist also zunächst einmal eine Bibliothek wie alle anderen auch. Sie ist jetzt nicht durch irgendeinen Staatsvertrag oder so in irgendeine andere Rolle gebracht und es ist auch keine Überbibliothek, die für andere Bibliotheken Dienstleistungen erbringt oder gibt es da nochmal einen Spin, den ich übersehe?
Das deutsche Bibliothekswesen ist ja durchaus kompliziert. Und als totaler Quereinsteiger, ich bin eigentlich Sozialwissenschaftler, fehlt mir da sicherlich auch in der Tiefe da nochmal was das angeht ein bisschen das Verständnis. Aber alles was du gerade gesagt hast ist gleichzeitig richtig. Das heißt also die Staatsbibliothek selber ist erst mal eine Bundesbehörde, also eine Bundeseinrichtung, gehört also nicht zur Stadt Berlin beispielsweise, sondern ist am Bund angesiedelt und wiederum Teil halt dieser Stiftung preußischer Kulturbesitz, wo beispielsweise auch viele bekannte Berliner Museen drin sind, wie irgendwie Pergamon-Museum beispielsweise. Und in dem Kontext spielt die Staatsbibliothek dann schon eine spezielle Rolle, aber die deutsche Nationalbibliothek beispielsweise die DNB mit ihren Standorten in Frankfurt und – wo ist jetzt der zweite – Leipzig, ich hoffe, ich sage jetzt nichts peinlichen, die spielt eigentlich diese Rolle als die zentrale zumindest Bibliothek der Neuzeit.
Wo auch wirklich jedes Werk, was in Deutschland erscheint muss halt sein Belegexemplar an die DNB in Frankfurt abliefern und jetzt nicht an die Staatsbibliothek Berlin. Es gibt beispielsweise auch eine Staatsbibliothek in München, die bayrische Staatsbibliothek BSB. Also es gibt mehrere Staatsbibliotheken. Selbst die SUB Göttingen, wo ich angefangen habe, in die Bibliothekswelt reinzuschnuppern, Staats- und Universitätsbibliothek Göttingen, kommt dann wiederum vom Staat Hannover wird das wieder abgeleitet. Also das Staat selber sagt da erst mal nicht allzu viel aus.
Es bezieht sich auch wenn dann mehr aufs Land, als auf irgendeinen Staat.
Genau, nichts desto trotz haben wir auch Sonderaufgaben, die keine andere Bibliothek in Deutschland hat, beispielsweise ich glaube die Bibliothekssiegel werden von uns vergeben, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Oder diese ISIL-Nummern, aber das ist dann jetzt schon wirklich relativ bibliotheksspezifische Geschichte.
Ja gut, aber ich meine daraus leitet sich ja im Prinzip ab, es ist schon ein ambitioniertes Projekt. Man beschäftigt sich jetzt nicht nur mit so ein paar Büchern und macht abends zu und das war es, sondern – und da fällt ja im Prinzip auch dein Bereich so ein basischen mit rein, sicherlich nicht der einzige, er da mit reinfällt – dass man sich eben Gedanken macht über das Bibliothekswesen als solches.
Richtig.
Bibliotheken gibt es natürlich schon lange so. Mythische Namen kommen da einem gleich ins Hirn. Die Bibliothek von Alexandria und all diese ganzen geschaffenen Orte. Also die Aufzeichnung des Wissens haben ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo es möglich war, mit Papyrus und später natürlich vor allem mit dem Buchdruck schon sind ein Teil auch der wissenschaftlichen Revolution. Hatten das ja hier auch schon öfter mal bei Forschergeist, wo wir uns mit Wissenschaftsforschern, Wissenschaftsgeschichtsforschern unterhalten haben, so dass man ja auch sieht, dass auch das Bild, was wir heute von der Wissenschaft haben, ein doch relativ neues ist. Dass so ein Wissenschaftler als solcher so vor 150 Jahren nicht so ohne weiteres von sich hätte sagen können, ja ich bin Wissenschaftler. Weil sich dann alle gefragt hätten, was soll das denn sein?
Heutzutage ist das halt eigentlich ein normales Ding und auch Wissenschaft ist an sich ein erkennbares Ding. Welche Rolle denkst du, wie kann man denn die Rolle der Bibliotheken konkret bewerten in Zusammenarbeit mit der Wissenschaft? Welche Rolle spielt die Bibliothek für die Wissenschaft? Weil man sie ja natürlich auch so als Volksbildungselement sehen kann.
Genau, also ob diese Unterscheidung im Detail immer so Sinn macht oder nicht zwischen quasi einer Stadtbibliothek und einer wissenschaftlichen Bibliothek, darüber könnte man jetzt ziemlich lange streiten. Ich finde die Unterscheidung jetzt gar nicht so zentral, weil die Grundaufgaben sind eigentlich immer dieselben von einer Bibliothek. Das ist am Anfang das Sammeln. Das heißt also man möchte irgendwie Bestände erwerben oder sie fallen einem zu und man hält sie fest und baut halt eine Sammlung auf, die man dann zugänglich macht. Der zweite klassische Schritt ist dann der der Erschließung oder Katalogisierung. Das heißt wenn ich da jetzt ein Buch stehen habe, dann möchte ich auch etwas darüber aussagen, was dieses Buch eigentlich ist. Also wie heißt es und wer ist der Autor und was ist der Verlag und wann wurde es publiziert und vielleicht möchte ich auch schon ein bisschen eine Sacherschließung machen, um was für Themen geht es eigentlich in diesem Buch. Und Ziel dieser Erschließung, also entsprechend mit Metadaten-Versehung von diesem Werk, ist dann eben das Verfügbarmachen, das ist dann die dritte große Säule.
Indem man auch meistens so was wie eine Benutzungsabteilung mit dranhängt. Das heißt also wie bekomme ich dann dieses Wissen wieder in die Welt hinaus, wie kann ich transparent machen, was haben wir in unserem Bestand, woraus baut sich unsere Sammlung auf, wie kann ich suchen nach etwas, wer kann mir Informationen geben? Also früher war ja eine der Hauptaufgaben von Bibliothekaren eben auch dieses Auskunftgeben über das was da ist. Also dass es einen Katalog gibt, in dem ich suchen kann, das ist eigentlich auch noch ein relativ neues Konzept. Gerade natürlich Digitalsuche ist noch wirklich jung. Also ich habe noch angefangen zu studieren, da hatten wir noch Zettelkästen, da gab es noch kein OPAC, in dem man irgendwie digital suchen konnte. Und da kommt auch so ein bisschen das klassische Selbstverständnis von Bibliothekaren eigentlich her, die lassen sich eigentlich immer einer dieser beiden Kategorien zuordnen, entweder sie Katalogisieren und Erschließen oder sie geben Auskunft über das was da ist.
Und jeder zumindest von denen, die es selber studiert habe, haben gesagt, früher oder später muss sich jeder eigentlich immer entscheiden, möchte ich eigentlich so in diese Richtung oder möchte ich in jene Richtung. Was liegt mir da mehr am Herzen. Das alleine bei mir am Schreibtisch mich mit einem Objekt beschäftigen und Aussagen darüber treffen oder quasi am Kunden, am Menschen arbeiten und dort Gedanken machen. Das ist so ein bisschen so das Grundset eigentlich, wie jede Bibliothek eigentlich funktioniert mehr oder weniger.
Also möchte ich eine Datenbank sein oder eine Suchmaschine?
Nein das trifft es nicht so ganz. Also Suchmaschine ja. Also die Bibliothekare sind schon menschliche Suchmaschinen, da könnte man jetzt auch lustige Döneken erzählen, was man da so für Skills braucht, um irgendwie mit Menschen umgehen zu können. Weil Menschen, das merkt man dann, wenn man wirklich an der Auskunft mal ist, sind absurd schlecht darin, zu formulieren, was sie eigentlich suchen. Vielleicht ein klassisches Beispiel, da war ich selber mit dabei. Es kommt also ein Kunde zum Tresen und sagt, er möchte jetzt was wissen über Prozessrecht. Was hätten wir denn an Büchern im Jurabereich zum Prozessrecht? Und dann fragt man halt ein bisschen weiter nach so, warum denn eigentlich genau und was will er denn? Und weil wir halt einen Schwerpunkt im Bereich Rechtswissenschaften haben, denkt man, er ist ein Wissenschaftler, der sich halt jetzt mit Jura auseinandersetzt. Aber je länger man dann so ein Auskunftsgespräch führt, hinterher war die Story die, er möchte also seinen Richter verklagen und möchte dem also Befangenheit unterstellen und ähnliches und es ist auch schon der dritte Richter.
Und wenn man ihn dann fragt, was denn mit seinen Anwälten ist, ja er hätte schon sechs Anwälte entlassen. Da merkt man, okay der will überhaupt gar nicht wissenschaftlich arbeiten, sondern das ist ein Querulant, der jetzt also irgendwie in die Stabi läuft, um von uns irgendwie juristische Beratung zu haben. Und das passiert halt erschütternd regelmäßig. Und so was können Menschen aber dann doch ganz gut. Gerade halt wenn sie dafür trainiert sind, so was rauszubekommen und nicht sofort dem ersten Instinkt hinterher zu laufen. Anderes schönes Beispiel, da war ich allerdings nicht selber dabei. Jemand fragt, was haben Sie denn an Büchern über Tattoos So dann denkt man natürlich zuerst, naja gut Indonesien und da sind sie irgendwie entstanden und was gibt es für verschiedene Motive und so was. Und zehn Minuten später kommt raus, er sucht ein medizinisches Werk, wie man Tattoos entfernt, weil er wollte seine Tattoos los werden. Also die Annahmen, die man immer macht, über das, was jemand anderes glaubt wissen zu wollen, die sind immer schwer zu hinterfragen.
Also die Geschichte der Bibliotheken ist eine Geschichte der Missverständnisse. Aber vielleicht wenn wir das Digitale an der Stelle mal ein bisschen ausklammern. Noch ein bisschen Verständnis für das Selbstverständnis auch zu gewinnen. Und auch zu verstehen, wo man eigentlich ansetzen muss mit einer erfolgreichen Digitalisierung. Wie funktioniert der Apparat denn sozusagen, bevor die Computer angefangen haben, alles auf den Kopf zu stellen?
Naja also man hatte halt seine Erwerbungsabteilung. Die macht sich Gedanken darüber, was ist eine gute Strategie, um einen Bestandsaufbau herzuführen. Das heißt also was gibt es an Neuerscheinungen in den verschiedenen Bereichen, die interessant sein könnten? Was ist auf dem Markt von Rara irgendwo unterwegs. Das heißt also, wo gibt es Auktionen? Also wertvolle alte Bücher werden häufig bei Auktionen versteigert. Was gibt es irgendwo an Nachlässen auf dem Markt? Das ist auch ein ganz interessanter Faktor. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt irgendwo jemand verstorben ist und sein gesamter Nachlass von irgendeinem wichtigen Künstler oder Wissenschaftler, dann bekommt man also dann große Kisten mit Material drin, völlig ungeordnet, völlig unsortiert. Möchte man so etwas erwerben? Also das ist erst mal die Frage der Erwerbungsabteilung.
Also eher so eine Detektivabteilung. Oder kauft ihr jetzt einfach so nach Gutdünken, so naja wir kaufen da mal zehn Bananenkisten, wird schon was brauchbares drin sein oder ist man schon so hinterher und versucht sozusagen, ganz bestimmte Objekte, von denen man auch weiß, dass es sie gibt, derer man nur noch nicht hat habhaft werden können?
Schon eher letzteres. Also letztendlich hat jede Bibliothek schon so etwas wie ein eigenes Erwerbungsprofil. Da ist es auch ganz interessant, sich das historisch anzugucken. Da bin ich nun wieder gar kein Experte, aber beispielsweise wie dort Konfessionsgrenzen eine Rolle spielen. Wo ich halt eigentlich herkomme ist SUB Göttingen, das war eine sehr protestantisch geprägte Bibliothek und die hatte da eine ganz andere Erwerbungsphilosophie als beispielsweise die bayrische Staatsbibliothek als katholisch geprägte Bibliothek. So dass also als beispielsweise die Google Books Digitalisierung losging und alle gesagt haben, oh mein Gott die Bayern digitalisieren jetzt so viel mit Google, da bleibt für uns gar nichts mehr da. Wenn man da mal wirklich in die Bestandslisten reinguckt, merkt man, mh die ganze Erwerbungsstrategie der Protestanten war doch ganz anders, die waren einfach an anderer Wissenschaft interessiert als die Katholiken. Bis hin zu wieder Beispiel Göttingen der Mathematikbereich. Da hat halt Gauß gearbeitet und gelehrt. Und alleine jetzt also aus dem Gauß-Nachlass ist also jetzt eine gewisse Verpflichtung quasi von Göttingen entstanden, wir wollen einfach so alles im Bereich der Mathematik sammeln, was nicht bei 3 auf den Bäumen ist.
Und irgendwie eine gewisse Qualität hat. Das heißt also, jede Bibliothek definiert für sich schon so gewisse Grundlinien, wo sie sich drauf spezialisiert und wo dann andere Bibliotheken dann auch nicht noch das 5. und 6. ähnliche Exemplar machen müssen, weil es natürlich dann auch entsprechende Austauschmechanismen zwischen Bibliotheken gibt, also Fernleihe ist da das Stichwort. Natürlich jetzt nicht von Rara und Unika und den ganzen wertvollen Sachen, sondern dann also wirklich halt von Feld-Wald-und-Wiesen-Objekten, die werden dann auch einfach durch die Republik versandt. Ich glaube da fängt es halt an. Man hat irgendwo so ein gewisses Portfolio als Bibliothek, was man eigentlich wie sammeln möchte und dann beispielsweise Fachreferenten sind dann diejenigen, die sich darum kümmern, das sind eigentlich ganz normale Akademiker und Wissenschaftler, die irgendwann in den Bereich der Bibliothek gewechselt sind und aber mit dem Hintergrund aus ihrer Fachrichtung wissen, das sind die relevanten Journals, das sind die relevanten Verlage, dort die Publikationslisten durchgehen. Was erscheint da neues? Sich dann auch durchaus absprechen im Verbund von mehreren Bibliotheken, wer erwirbt jetzt was? Dass nicht alle dasselbe irgendwie erwerben müssen.
Und erworben wird aber sagen wir mal mehr Bücher. Also es geht jetzt nicht um wissenschaftliche Paper zum Beispiel oder werden die bei euch auch?
Fast nur noch letzteres.
Tatsächlich?
Ja also der Bruch ist glaube ich schon vor 20 Jahren oder so was erfolgt. Aber einfach als ganz zwangsläufige Reaktion darauf, wie der Wissenschaftsbetrieb dort umgebrochen ist. Das heißt also die große Monografie, wo also ein Wissenschaftler völlig solitär irgendwo vor sich hinforscht, die ist noch vorhanden, sagen wir mal im Bereich er Promotion oder wenn man eine Habil schreibt, da ist das noch irgendwie so das Werk.
Oder wenn man mal sein Lebenswerk abkippt.
Aber ansonsten ist das Ding der Stunde, und zwar nicht der Stunde, sondern der letzten 20 Jahre sind natürlich wissenschaftliche Aufsätze. Also in Journals halt. Also wenn du Naturwissenschaftler bist, dann willst du in Nature publizieren. Da willst du keine Monografie schreiben. Und dann gibt es ja auch diese Mechanismen wie Impact-Faktor, das heißt also wie viel Wert auf dem Akademikermarkt ist eigentlich eine Publikation, in was für verschiedenen Bereichen? Und da ist natürlich eine einzige Publikation innerhalb von einer solchen wirklich sehr wertvollen peer reviewten Journal, wie eben Nature viel viel mehr wert, als irgendeine Monografie, die du irgendwo im Selbstverlag rausgekippt hast.
Aber wenn das schon bei Nature publiziert worden ist, was braucht die Staatsbibliothek dann noch ihre Finger da dran?
Naja, du musst beispielsweise den Zugang zu Nature bereitstellen, das ist nämlich teuer, vorsichtig ausgedrückt so. Wo wir jetzt auch schon in so ein Themengebiet reinkommen. Also wie gesagt, das wird jetzt viel viel mehr. Also Wissenschaft findet heutzutage in wissenschaftlichen Zeitschriften statt. Und eigentlich nur noch zu dem fast vernachlässigten Teil in Monografien. Bei Lehrbüchern sieht es anders aus. Also wenn es darum geht, jetzt irgendwie im universitären Bereich das Grundlagenwerk VWL, BWL, wie auch immer, das hast du dann natürlich als Lehrbuch. Mittlerweile auch digital, aber nichts desto trotz da spielen Bücher schon noch eine Rolle. Aber wenn es jetzt wirklich um Grundlagenforschung und um das geht, wo wirklich gerade die Wissenschaft stattfindet, das ist ausschließlich eigentlich im Bereich der Zeitschriften unterwegs. Und die kosten auch einfach wahnsinnig viel. Das heißt also, da geht auch vom Erwerbungsetat der ganz überwiegende Teil rein.
Aber das ist ja dann kein Kauf, das ist ja dann sozusagen nur so einen Zugang legen?
Das ist im digitalen Bereich leider richtig und finde ich ein großes Ärgernis, was viele zurecht im Bibliotheksbereich aufregt. Früher war es halt so, du hast den Journal abonniert und hast dann dein Vierteljahresheft bekommen mit irgendwie, was weiß ich, 400 Aufsätzen drin oder weniger, ist auch egal, so und das hast du ins Regal gestellt und dann hattest du es. Es war in deinem Besitz. Aber jetzt ist es halt eigentlich so wie bei Spotify, das einzelne Musikstück gehört dir nicht mehr, sondern du hast quasi nur eine Streaming-Lizenz und kannst es dir zwar ganz häufig anhören und ist soweit alles sehr schön komfortabel. Aber wenn Spotify irgendwann mal den Server abschaltet, dann ist deine Musik auch weg. Und ähnlich verhält sich das jetzt mit elektronischen Abonnements.
Aber das muss doch einen klassischen Bibliothekar die Decke hochtreiben. Das ist doch sozusagen das schlimmste.
Ja das ist eine Pille, die ist hart zu schlucken. Weil natürlich so der eigene Bestand, das ist auch etwas, ich hatte das am Anfang ein bisschen gesagt, so mit dieser Sammlungshistorie, darüber definiert sich natürlich auch eine Bibliothek. Und wir kommen jetzt aber unweigerlich in eine Zeit, in der Bestand für eine Bibliothek glaube ich keine Kategorie mehr ist, die wirklich zukunftsfähig ist. Das wird noch so 10 Jahre dauern, bis der Prozess ganz abgeschlossen ist, aber das Beispiel von Spotify ist da schon glaube ich ganz hilfreich. Klar man sammelt noch irgendwie Vinyl und findet das vielleicht noch irgendwie romantisch. Mach ich auch. Aber letztendlich kann man sich dem glaube ich nicht verschließen, dass diese Streaming-Module und diese Auflösung des Haptischen und des Materiellen, dass das einfach relativ unweigerlich die Richtung ist, in die es geht.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, damals musste eine Bibliothek schon abbrennen, damit das Weltwissen verschwindet. Jetzt reicht schon eine geschlossene ISDN-Leitung im übertragenen Sinne. Das ist ja eigentlich ein hoch beunruhigender Punkt. Vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal ein Querverweis auf ein Gespräch, was ich hier vor einiger Zeit schon geführt habe mit Nikolaus Kriegeskorte, da ging es halt um OpenScience, wo wir diesen ganzen Publikationsprozess, wie er eben derzeit heutzutage ist, auch nochmal genauer unter die Lupe genommen haben bzw. auch darauf dann schon Schlussfolgerungen gezogen haben, hin eben zu einem neuen Modell, in dem halt Publikationswesen offen stattfindet. Sieht sich denn die Bibliothek da auch als Partner der Wissenschaft, um diesen Prozess voranzutreiben?
Ich würde sogar sagen, wir sind einer der Hauptmotoren dieses Prozesses. Also OpenAccess, unter dem das ja dann auch ein bisschen läuft und OpenAccess-Publikation vielmehr, also OpenAccess würde ja erst mal nur sagen, der Zugang ist frei zu wissen. Aber der Weg des OpenAccess-Publizierens, der wurde schon in den letzten Jahren und auch viele Jahre schon relativ maßgeblich von den Bibliotheken mit vorangetrieben, eben aus dieser totalen Unzufriedenheit, dass jetzt plötzlich Verlage wie Elsevier mit irgendwelchen astronomischen Steigerungsraten ihre Abogebühren dazukommen. Auf der anderen Seite einem selber eigentlich nichts mehr gehört. Sondern man eben nur noch den Zugriff bekommt. Und ja also das ist auch innerhalb des deutschen Bibliothekswesens also völlig Common Sense, dass also OpenAccess-Publikationen definitiv das ist, was unterstützenswert ist. Inklusive auch, dass wir Repositories anbieten.
Also wenn man sich beispielsweise mal BASE aus Bielefeld anguckt, das ist also glaube ich doch Deutschlands größtes OpenAccess-Repository, da ist auch schon ganz gut was vorhanden. Die Crux an der ganzen Konstruktion, aber jetzt müssen wir nicht eure alte Folge nochmal wiederholen, ist eben genau wieder dieser Faktor oder dieser Aspekt des Impact Faktors. Das heißt also die Wissenschaft muss natürlich auch auf der anderen Seite mitziehen und muss ihre Gratifikationsanreize und Gratifikationssysteme anpassen. Und sagen, okay Nature ist nicht OpenAccess und damit sinkt dann da jetzt mal der Impact Faktor und stattdessen wird es wichtiger in einer OpenAccess-Journal zu publizieren. Davon sind wir noch sehr sehr weit entfernt.
Aber man ist auf dem Weg?
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe. Aber weißt du, das Verhältnis von Wissenschaft zu Bibliotheken ist manchmal wirklich ein erstaunliches. Das ist aber auch der Grund, warum ich so gerne in einer Bibliothek arbeite und nicht selber letztendlich dann Wissenschaftler geworden bin. Wir haben auch häufig Projekte, in denen wir dann also mit Wissenschaftlern zusammen in Kooperation sind und sagen, so jetzt digitalisieren wir euch mal Werk XY und stellen das schon mal online und darüber forscht ihr dann und darüber könnt ihr dann publizieren. Und dann kommen die zu einem und sagen, ja das digitalisieren Sie mal, das ist schon gut, aber dann stellen Sie es mal ein Jahr lang noch nicht online, weil ich möchte da erst mal alleine drüber forschen und dann können Sie es irgendwann mal öffentlich zuggängig machen, wenn ich meine Publikation rausgehauen habe. Ansonsten kommt nämlich XY aus Regensburg dazwischen und publiziert was schneller als ich. Das heißt also in dem Mindset von Wissenschaft ist eben diese Klandestinität, dieses so, ich habe jetzt irgendwo meine Forschungsfrage, und auf der sitze ich jetzt erst mal und auf der möchte ich auch aber auch drei Jahre bitte schön unangefochten sitzen.
Das führt bei der Frage von Zugänglichmachung von Information durchaus zu Interessenkonflikten.
Man sieht das auch in der Raumfahrt ganz stark. Da ist das auch ein starkes Thema.
Ernsthaft? Das überrascht mich jetzt fast.
Naja ich meine, da sind dann die Satelliten unterwegs, und man fragt sich, ja wo sind denn jetzt die geilen Bilder? Die geilen Bilder kriegt ihr dann in nem Jahr, weil jetzt müssen halt erst mal die Forscher darüber brüten und ihre Papers schreiben und dann dürfen die anderen halt auch mal. Aber auch das ändert sich gerade und da befindet sich gerade viel in Bewegung. Aber die Fragestellung ist natürlich an der Stelle genau die gleiche.
Also ich war ja selber auch mal doch ein wenig Wissenschaftler so in meinen ersten akademischen Jahren.
Ich dachte schon Astronaut.
Ich wollte mein Leben lang Arzt werden. Und ich kann das natürlich schon nachvollziehen. Also mir sind auch drei Promotionsthemen irgendwie quasi weggeschossen worden so, wo dann irgendjemand anders dann schon wieder schneller und effizienter war und das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich es dann nie mit der Promotion durchgezogen habe. Dieses klandestine Moment in der Wissenschaft, das ist erst mal nicht wegzudiskutieren. Das ist eine gute Überlebensstrategie, so zu verfahren. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es gesamtgesellschaftlich natürlich schon ein bisschen problematisch. Also wir hatten jetzt selbst bei unserer größten Erwerbung in der Stabi in den letzten Jahren, das waren die Tagebücher Alexander von Humboldt, gab es also auch dort durchaus Bestrebungen innerhalb des Projektteams auf Seiten der Wissenschaft, naja also wenn Sie die online stellen, dann doch bitte erst mal nicht in so einer guten Auflösung. Gerade bei Humboldt, der hat halt super klein und fein gekrickelt, können wir vielleicht mal ein Link zu unseren Scans mal mit in die Shownotes einbauen, das ist schon spektakulär, was der für ein Wissensmanagementsystem auf einer DIN A4-Seite quasi entwickelt hat.
Wo er das wo wie in welchem Winkel noch dazu notiert hat und mit Draufklebzetteln und ähnliches. Aber selbst da, das war jetzt gerade mal vor zwei Jahren, gab es also durchaus Druck auf die Stabi, mal nicht so schnell und nicht so in guter Qualität. Aber darüber haben wir uns dann auch einfach mal hinweggesetzt und haben es dann trotzdem gemacht. Aber es gibt da durchaus einen Konflikt zwischen dem was Bibliotheken wollen, nämlich alles Wissen frei für alle und dem was Wissenschaftler dort wollen. Wo wie gesagt diese Klandestinität durchaus ein bisschen eingebaut ist.
Gut jetzt haben wir glaube ich diesen Bereich des Erwerbs nochmal ganz gut beleuchtet und auch schon die damit verbundenen Fragen der späteren Publikation. Aber um vielleicht nochmal diesen Prozess ein bisschen zu verstehen, jetzt haben wir als zweite wichtige Phase eben diese Erschließung und die Katalogisierung, haben wir jetzt auch schon gehört an dem Beispiel dieser Wiedervereinigung der beiden Hälften der Staatsbibliothek. Wenn dann mal so zwei verschiedene Schemata am Start sind innerhalb derselben Organisation, dann ist das schon ein Problem. Und dann hat man da ein paar Jahrzehnte mit zu kämpfen. Jetzt würde ich mal meinen, wenn man dann schon innerhalb einer solchen Struktur, gut ich meine da war jetzt eine Systemtrennung dazwischen, aber dass es dann wahrscheinlich auch zwischen Bibliotheken und auch auf internationaler Ebene jetzt auch nicht so, dass es sozusagen nur ein Maß gibt, mit dem gearbeitet wird?
Da würde ich fast sagen, na zum Glück doch. Allerdings nicht eines, sondern dutzende.
So nach dem Motto, Standrads sind toll, wir sollten mehr davon haben?
Ja exakt. Ganz genau. Und da sind Bibliotheken aber auch wirklich gut drin. Und da waren sie auch im digitalen Bereich finde ich sehr früh sehr gut. Also Standards in Bibliotheken das ist schon eine glückliche Hochzeit eigentlich immer gewesen. Das heißt also wir haben sehr sehr simple Standards, womit irgendwie jeder vernünftig umgehen kann. Das bekannteste wäre hier sicherlich Dublin Core, oder abgekürzt DC, was ein Metadatenstandard ist zur Beschreibung von Objekten, wo glaube ich insgesamt irgendwie acht Felder oder zehn Felder überhaupt nur drin sind.
Ja aber eigentlich so als Internetstandard eigentlich geboren wurde?
Da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher. Da müssten wir mal gucken. Also es war wirklich in Dublin, darum auch Dublin Core. Aber dann kommt man halt relativ schnell dazu, okay …
Also die Dublin Core Metadata Initiative heißt es ja eigentlich, beschreibt halt Elemente von Dingen und ist dabei sehr allgemein. Zumindest fängt es erst mal sehr allgemein an und dann wird es immer detaillierter und es gibt halt dann auch von Anfang an, oder zumindest kenne ich das jetzt gar nicht anders, eben auch ganz klare Niederschriften, wie das denn so digital abzubilden ist und es streut sich so in alles überall ein wenig mit rein. Aber das spielt eine große Rolle in der Bibliothek?
Nicht mehr wirklich. Aber das war so ca. vor 10 Jahren oder so was sicherlich. Erstmal so ein Grundstandard, auf dem man schon mal gut operieren und wo man sich schon mal gut drauf einigen konnte, um schon mal irgendwie Sachen vernünftig auszutauschen.
Ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeschaut. Also es ist, wie ich es auch richtig erinnert habe, 94 im Rahmen einer frühen www-Konferenz gestartet worden das Projekt. Also ist für die auch ein Kind der digitalen Zeit.
Aber man kommt halt auch relativ schnell dazu, dass halt bestehende Standards dann auch einfach nicht das abdecken, was man gerade irgendwie braucht. Und was aber auch wirklich dann so an Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler hinten nützlich ist. Mal ein Beispiel von einem Standard, den wir selber mit entwickelt haben, ist der zur Beschreibung von einfach digitalisierten alten Büchern. Also wir haben ja damals im Digitalisierungszentrum in Göttingen, was ich ja dann eine Zeit lang auch geleitet habe, haben wir halt eben wirklich in großem Maßstab Massendigitalisierung betrieben und haben also dann gemeinfreie Bücher, das heißt also Werke, wo der Autor 70 Jahre verstorben ist. Es zählt ja immer nicht das Datum des Werks an sich, sondern Tod des Autors für das Urheberrecht hier. Das haben wir genommen, unter einen teuren wirklich sehr sehr guten Buchscanner gelegt und dann halt digitalisiert online gestellt. Und nur die Scans selber sind dann aber von der Usability her, wenn ich dann als Wissenschaftler mit diesem Dokument arbeiten möchte, eben schon ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Weil ich habe dann erst mal nur so eine Bildsequenz halt, die auch relativ wenig aussagt. Und aus unserem Katalogsystem, aus dem OPAC, bekomme ich halt nur die bibliografischen Metadaten. Das heißt also Titel, Autor, Jahr und so weiter. Aber über die eigentliche Struktur des Bandes, beispielsweise das Inhaltsverzeichnis, sagt mir das nichts aus. Und dann hat also damals in meiner Abteilung Markus Enders, der ist jetzt in der British Library, hat das ganz entscheidend mit der Library of Congress mit geprägt, einen neuen Metadatenstandard aufgesetzt, nämlich METS/MODS. Also im Wesentlichen METS, Mets ist da der entscheidende Standard, der nämlich das Problem gelöst hat, wie man eine logische Struktur und eine physische Struktur von einem Buchobjekt zusammenbringt. So was meint man damit? Mn hat also zum einen seine Image-Sequenz. Sagen wir mal, ein Buch hat jetzt 100 Seiten, dann habe ich also Scans, die von 00 bis 100 quasi irgendwie hochzählen, mehr oder weniger. Dann habe ich als die eigentliche physische Sequenz ist aber das was drauf gedruckt ist an Seitenzahlen.
So und da sieht man nämlich, die ersten fünf Scans, die haben beispielsweise lateinische Nummerierungen, dann sind drei Seiten, die sind überhaupt nicht nummeriert und danach geht es dann mit arabischer Zählung weiter, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So Einführungskapitel etc.
Genau, und dann gerade bei historischen Werken geht das also wirklich Kraut und Rüben. Dann fangen sie plötzlich irgendwann mal wieder mit 1 an zu zählen, ohne dass man es gemerkt hat, weil irgendwas anderes eingebunden ist, wie auch immer, das ist also das schiere Chaos. Wenn man diese Sequenz aber abbildet auch, das heißt also dann wirklich ein Tool hat, wo man sagen kann, das sind jetzt die Paginierungssequenzen, und das dann wiederum mappt auf die Scans, kann man in der Nutzeroberfläche den Nutzern anbieten, der sagt so, ich weiß jetzt, dass die Passage, die mich interessiert, ist auf der aufgedruckten Seite 35, kann man ihm dann wirklich den richtigen Scan dazu raussuchen.
Das ist nicht nur die 35. Seite im Scan.
Genau, die ist in nahezu 100% aller Fälle falsch.
Ja das kennt man ja auch selbst.
Und dann kann ich auch wiederum noch die logische Pagenierungssequenz dazusetzen, das ist dann nämlich die Inhaltserschließungsebene. Das heißt also, wo beginnt welcher Artikel, wo beginnt welches Kapitel, wo sind irgendwo noch Tabellen eingebunden, wie auch immer? Das ist dann noch die dritte Ebene, die da noch mit reinmappt. Und diese drei Ebenen miteinander zu verzahnen, das heißt also, dass die Scanreihenfolge, die aufgedruckten Seitenzahlen und dann die eigentliche Inhaltsstrukturierung, das alles drei zusammenzubringen, dafür gab es einfach überhaupt gar keinen Metadatenstandard, der das auch nur ansatzweise gelöst hätte.
Und das liefert jetzt dieser Metadata Encoding and Transmission Standard, wie das so schön heißt?
Genau. Der ist also XML, wie so ziemlich alles, was wir irgendwie im Bibliotheksbereich jetzt machen an Metadaten, und der musste dann einfach mal so erfunden werden. Und der hat sich dann auch in der deutschen Digitalisierungsszene, dank den DFG-Richtlinien, die den dann sehr schnell adaptiert haben, dann auch breit durchgesetzt. Und jetzt kann man wunderbar eigentlich Digitalisate austauschen zwischen Bibliotheken. Es ist also egal, in welchem Digitalisierungszentrum die gemacht worden sind. So lange es irgendwie DFG-gefördert war, kann man sich einigermaßen sicher sein, dass dahinter auch irgendwie ein METS/MODS ist und so konnte man dann beispielsweise auch einen zentralen Viewer entwickeln. Den sogenannten DFG-Viewer.
Wenn Mets dieser Encoding-Standard ist, was ist dann MODS?
METS ist letztendlich dann der langweiligere Part, das sind eigentlich nur die bibliografischen Metadaten. Das ist also eine etwas elaboriertere Form von Dublin Core, wenn man so will. Also ist jetzt wirklich relativ schräg. Also MODS beschreibt wirklich nur die bibliografischen Daten, die man so auch im OPAC finden würde zu dem Objekt. Und METS geht dann wirklich in diese Struktur des Objektes rein.
Also MODS mit D.
Das könnte man auch in METS selber modellieren, aber das würde nicht so viele Vorteile bringen.
Also METS ist sozusagen die Klammer, und da kommt dann alles andere mit rein.
So und dann hat die DFG gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht wann das war, ich würde auch sagen so vor acht Jahren oder ähnlichem, die haben gesagt, sie finden es irgendwie gar nicht mal so töfte, dass jetzt jedes Digitalisierungszentrum jeder Bibliothek eine andere Nutzeroberfläche für ihre Scans hat. Und die Wissenschaftler denen ist das relativ egal, ob jetzt irgendwas in München oder in Berlin oder in Halle digitalisiert worden ist und die müssen jedes mal, wo sie irgendwie das Objekt dann jeweils finden, müssen sie sich wieder auf eine andere Nutzung einstellen und dann hat die DFG gesagt, so wo wir doch jetzt ohnehin schon alle mit einem einheitlichen Metadatenmodell unterwegs sind, bieten wir doch alternativ zu den ganzen lokalen Implementierungen noch einen zentralen Viewer an, den sogenannten DFG-Viewer, was man sich so als quasi PDF-Viewer vorstellen kann. Der also immer gleich aussieht. Und in den kann man dann rein laden seine Scans von den ganz unterschiedlichen Bibliotheken und hat dann eine einheitliche Bedienung. Und solche Konzepte werden dann plötzlich möglich, dadurch dass man sich einfach mal auf einheitliche Metadatenstandards einigt. Das war eine total prima Herangehensweise.
Man kann jetzt darüber streiten, ob dieser DFG-Viewer selber nun das Maß aller Dinge in Sachen Usability ist. Also wir nutzen beispielsweise oder entwickeln in Berlin auch mit großem Aufwand einen eigenen Viewer, weil wir denken, dass da viele Funktionalitäten noch anders umgesetzt werden sollten. Aber was das so an Vereinheitlichung von Prozessen dann an Bibliotheken bewirkt, das alleine war die Initiative schon wert. Also alle machen mal so in etwa, also alle wollen sowieso meistens dasselbe im Bibliothekswesen, das ist das schöne, darum mag ich das auch so. Da gibt es relativ wenig Hidden Genders so, sondern man will halt einfach so Wissen rausbringen in die Welt und erschließbar machen und jetzt hat man auch einheitliche Verfahren dazu, das ist gut. Und so könnte man das jetzt noch auf zehn andere Metadatenstandars irgendwie durch iterieren, also TEI beispielsweise, wenn man dann zu Volltexten kommt, wie man das also dann entsprechend beschreibt. Weil nun wiederum die Image-Digitalisate nur so eine Brückentechnologie sind, hin zu eigentlich will man das was geschrieben steht auf der Seite erfassen.
Zwar dann auch computerlesbar und durchsuchbar und in seine eigene Wissenschaftsumgebung kopierbar. Da hätte man dann solche Standards wie TEI und dann kann man die wieder mit METS/MODS kombinieren.
Also TEI ist die Text Encoding Initiative. Okay und da geht es dann sozusagen ums Eingemachte. Nicht nur jetzt mal zu sagen, es gibt hier Seiten und irgendwo ist da auch Inhalt, sondern hier geht es auch darum, sozusagen den Inhalt als solchen abzubilden. Also Hierarchien und Bezüge abzubilden.
Genau und bis in absurd anmutende Details.
Erfunden wurde TEI, um Shakespeare Sonette zu beschreiben. Und mittlerweile gibt es auch eine Menge Erweiterungen.
Zum Beispiel?
Was ist denn an diesen Shakespeare Sonetten so komplex, dass man dafür einen eigenen XML-Standard machen muss?
Die waren ehrlich gesagt dann noch nicht wirklich sonderlich komplex. Aber beispielsweise was man mit TEI jetzt gut machen kann ist Annotationen mit reingeben. Das heißt also ich habe irgendwie ein Werk in Schreibmaschine getippt, wo ich dann also auch in TEI genau sagen kann, da sind jetzt hier die Absätze gesetzt worden und dann gibt es handschriftliche Sachen, wo Sachen durchgestrichen worden sind handschriftlich und irgendwie andere Begriffe drüber geschrieben worden sind beispielsweise. So was kann ich in TEI schon sehr exakt modellieren. Auch dann inklusive so in was für einem Winkel ist das geschrieben worden? Das kann man dann also beliebig komplex machen. Also wenn dann irgendwie so die … von daher wieder zu den Humboldt Tagebüchern, die könnte man ziemlich gut in TEI erfassen. Das ist eine Höllenarbeit, aber würde sich durchaus eignen dafür.
Ich würde sagen, jetzt fragt sich ein Zuhörer wahrscheinlich, wieso muss ich den Winkel, in dem ein handschriftlicher Vermerk auf irgendeinem alten Papier vermerkt ist, so digital abbilden?
Da würde ich jetzt sagen, nur weil uns dafür heute noch keine sinnvolle Wissenschaftsfrage einfällt, heißt das nicht, dass die nicht übermorgen irgendwo um die Ecke kommt.
Wie Handschriftforscher. Sagt der Winkel in dem die Korrekturen verfasst werden etwas über den geistigen Zustand?
Na gut, das ist jetzt schon fast naheliegend. Aber die Diskussion wurde auch in den Digiitalisierungszentren sehr früh schon geführt, in welcher Qualität wollen wir eigentlich digitalisieren? Weil damals war das alles durchaus noch teuer. So Auflösung, Speicher war teuer, Bandbreite war teuer. Das war durchaus eine Abwägungsfrage, wie gut scannen wir jetzt, dafür dass es good enough ist für die Wissenschaftler und die damit irgendwie vernünftig arbeiten können. Und meine persönliche Positionierung war dazu immer, dass wir heute eigentlich keinerlei Vorstellung darüber haben, was morgen Wissenschaftsfragen sein werden. Und von daher ist es eigentlich unser Job an Bibliotheken, es so gut wie nur irgendwie möglich zu machen.
Und dann auch vielleicht etwas verkopfter da ranzugehen, als es andere in dem Moment glauben wollen.
Ganz genau. Und von daher, grundsätzlich zu sagen, okay wir machen jetzt lieber ein bisschen too much und haben dann ein bisschen Puffer in die Zukunft hinein, auch wenn das natürlich nicht ewig halten wird. Aber auch da, das sind immer alles so Abwägungsfragen. Es kann auch das Gegenteil mal eine sehr gute Strategie sein. Also beispielsweise hatten wir aus der Not heraus in Göttingen am Anfang vor allen Dingen Scanner, die nur bitonal scannen konnten, das heißt nur schwarz-weiß. Die konnten also schlecht Graustufen und gar keine Farbe. Und da könnte man sagen, naja was dann da an Scans rauskommt, das ist dann irgendwie eher nicht so dolle dann. Wenn ich also einen historischen Druck auf vergilbtem Papier habe, da geht ja schon irgendwie eine ganze Menge verloren.
Ja da kann man die Gilbstufe gar nicht richtig abbilden.
Ganz genau also für so ein Wissenschaftsszenario wäre das dann … oder ein Wasserzeichen oder ähnliches, Druckermarken, komme ich da noch viel schlechter dran, bei so einer Scantechnologie. Aber für andere Nutzungsszenarien war das wiederum perfekt. Denn diese Scanner hatten eine extrem gute Optik. Dadurch dass sie halt nicht auf Farbe verzichten konnten, waren also einfach die Scanpannels von einer sehr höherwertigen Qualität.
Weil sie auf Farbe verzichten konnten.
Naja weil sie keine Farbfilter drin haben mussten.
Konnte man das alles sehr klein bauen und dann kriegt es auch noch die kleinsten Pixel. Von was für einer Auflösung reden wir da gerade?
Saubere echte 600 dpi. Und das war für Buchscanner damals wirklich ungewöhnlich hoch. Und wir reden hier halt wirklich von optisch sauber aufgelösten 600 dpi und nicht von zusammengeschummelten interpolierten und so. Dafür haben wir dann nämlich so schöne Messcharts.
Von welchem Jahrhundert sprechen wir jetzt gerade?
Von welchem  Zeitraum reden wir jetzt gerade, also von welchem Damals reden jetzt gerade?
Von Scannertechnologie?
Das war so Anfang 2000er, also 2003. Ich habe am GDZ angefangen und dann die Leitung übernommen 2005 so, und da war das schon gut abgehangen die Technologie. So und der Clou ist jetzt aber folgender. Du hast jetzt also dieses alte Buch, auf dem jetzt schon eigentlich die eigentliche Information in schwarzer Druckertinte drauf gedruckt ist und scannst das sauber bitonal in 600 dpi. Dann hast du die Möglichkeit, daraus, wenn du es einfach gar nicht weiter modifizierst, mit dem sogenannten Fax G4 Standard, der wirklich von den Faxgeräten kommt, ein TIFF abzuspeichern, was irre klein ist, weil es einfach sehr sehr gut komprimieren kann, weil es halt wirklich nur 0 und 1 hat, das ist halt bitonal. Und die kannst du dann wiederum in ein sehr sehr kleines PDF binden. Das heißt du kannst als Wissenschaftler, das kann man beim GDZ die alten bitonalen Sachen wirklich sind ja alle noch da, da kann man sich ein PDF runterladen, wo du also 100 Seiten sind da kein MB groß und du hast das ganze Buch. Und jetzt guckst du dir das am Bildschirm an und es ist so okayish und jetzt druckst du das auf deinem Laserdrucker aus.
Dein Laserdrucker hat 600 dpi, das heißt Scanauflösung ist exakt gleich Printauflösung. Und dann hast du dieses Papier vor dir, und du hast quasi ein Reprint des Originals vor der Nase. Auf dem du dann sowieso irgendwie Papier, dann wunderbar noch rummalen kannst und im rechten Winkel deine Korrekturen dazu verfassen kannst. Das heißt also, hier hast du plötzlich jetzt einen Workflow, wo gerade das Wegwerfen von Informationen, nämlich von Farbinformation, bei gleichzeitig einem Anheben von anderen Informationen, nämlich die Auflösung, und quasi ein Mapping auf das, wie die Leute hinterher wissenschaftlich damit praktikabel arbeiten können, nämlich ihren 600 dpi Laserdrucker schwarz-weiß natürlich – also bei Farbdruckern klappt das dann wiederum nicht – plötzlich dann eine Produktionskette hast, wo du für lau den Leuten Reprints anbieten kannst, die sie selber zu Hause herstellen für ihre ganz spezifischen Szenarien. Also von daher, diese ganz einfache Formel so, man macht immer so viel und so gut wie irgendwie möglich, manchmal lohnt es sich auch, einen Schritt zur Seite zu gehen und das Problem nochmal aus einer ganz anderen Perspektive sich anzuschauen. Da kann auch Gold am Wegesrand liegen.
War das jetzt schon geplant oder war das eher ein Unfall?
Sagen wir mal so, das war eigentlich eine technische Limitierung. So die Geräte konnten halt nichts anderes.
Hat sich nur gezeigt, ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee.
Genau, und dann promotet man das einfach als Feature, was man schon immer so haben wollte und das ist ja das, was Innovationsmanager in der Regel so machen. Man nimmt das, was ohnehin da ist und framt das einfach vernünftig. Aber das ist, darüber kann man sich jetzt lustig machen, aber wenn man dann nämlich zu dieser Vermittlungsebene von Bibliotheken kommt, finde ich ist das genau der Job von Bibliotheken. Leuten auch sagen, hey schaut mal hier, da sind Tools, da sind Werkzeuge, da sind Verfahren, so könnt ihr irgendwie prima Wissenschaft betreiben.
Aber bevor wir in den Bereich vorstoßen, wir reden ja jetzt im Prinzip noch über diesen Erschließungs- und Katalogierungsmetadatenbeschreibungsprozess. In welchem Gesamtzustand befindet sich denn da das Bibliothekswesen? Also es gibt viele Standards, jeder kann sich den aussuchen, den er gerade haben möchte.
Also für die Kernbibliotheksdaten gibt es sehr sehr wenige, sehr gut abgehangene Standards.
Also wie groß ist der Grad an Internationalisierung und Harmonisierung an der Stelle? So dass man eben auch übergreifend und nicht nur im Rahmen eines nationalen oder sehr regionalen Fokus vielleicht arbeiten kann? Und wie gut aufgestellt ist das? Also ist eigentlich schon alles da, was im Prinzip alle Fragen an der Stelle der Zukunft vielleicht beantworten kann? Hat man die richtigen Werkzeuge? Werden sie denn auch in dem Maße schon zum Einsatz gebracht, wie es angemessen wäre? Also ist das sozusagen schon so ein Bereich, der gut läuft oder befindet sich das gerade noch am Anfang?
Auch hier würde ich sagen, beides ist der Fall. Also wir können auf jeden Fall schon mal festhalten, dass Bibliotheken generell eine sehr sehr gesunde Einstellung zu Kooperation und zu Standardisierung haben. Das heißt also sowohl auf internationaler Ebene findet da viel statt, als auch gerade jetzt hier national. Also beispielsweise die ganze Erschließung ist eigentlich auf wenige Verbünde in Deutschland konzentriert. Ich glaube fünf sind es jetzt derzeit. Wir gehören hier in Berlin mit zum Göttinger Bibliotheksverbund GBV und dort sind es dann also ich glaube im GBV 12 Bibliotheken, wo dann irgendwie so was, die also gemeinsam katalogisieren und erschließen. Das heißt also, wenn irgendwo ein neues Werk angeschafft wird, dann erschließt eine Bibliothek macht die Tiefenerschließung und alle anderen nutzen das dann einfach nach für ihre Exemplare, so sie das Werk dann auch haben. Und das passiert seit ewigen Jahren schon so. Und es gibt jetzt gerade eine Initiative noch die Anzahl von Verbünden in Deutschland zu reduzieren, aber schon wieder hier relativ nebensächlich.
Das heißt also auf der Ebene der bibliothekarischen Kernstandards sagen wir mal sind wir schon seit vielen vielen Jahren extrem gut aufgestellt und da gilt auch immer dieses Grundmissionstatement, so das ist das auch gut und richtig und das will man weiter so machen. Wenn du jetzt fragst, wie zukunftssicher ist das Ganze? Da fällt die Antwort dann ein bisschen schwieriger aus. Also beispielsweise wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt, ich sagte ja eben schon, diese Scans sind eigentlich eine Brückentechnologie hin zum Volltext, und viele ganz ganz spannende Zukuntsthemen werden auf Volltext passieren. Stichwort BigData und ähnliches. Und da ist es beispielsweise jetzt unser PICA-System, das wir jetzt an der Stabi im Einsatz haben, von unserem Katalog. Wo also unser ganzer Hauptbestand drin erfasst ist, der kann halt beispielsweise nicht mit Volltext umgehen. Das heißt also, da kann ich zwar die bibliografischen Metadaten reingeben, das was wir eben schon so auch mit Dublin-Core und MODS beschrieben hatten, das kriege ich da ziemlich gut rein.
Wer ist der Autor etc., wann ist das erschienen?
So wenn ich ein Inhaltsverzeichnis reinbringen will, muss ich schon ganz schön mit Hängen und Würgen anfangen, das dann noch irgendwie zumindest so als Scan kann man es noch irgendwie mit reingeben so, aber bei Volltext hört es dann einfach mal komplett auf. Dafür sind die Systeme einfach nicht gedacht. Die kommen halt irgendwie so von der Grundkonstruktion eher so aus den 70ern/80erm und da war Volltext einfach noch nicht wirklich vorstellbar, würde ich sogar fast sagen. Oder könnte man vielleicht von träumen, aber OCR beispielsweise war da einfach noch Lichtjahre von entfernt, dass man da irgendwas vernünftig hinzufügen konnte.
Ist das sozusagen so ein bisschen das digitale Äquivalent zum Mikrofilm ja?
Ja.
Wir können dir hier so die optische Ansicht liefern und welche optische Ansicht jetzt geliefert werden soll, das lässt sich gut finden und herausfinden. Aber dass sozusagen das Digitalisat den eigentlich Inhalt bereits auch vollständig versteht, inklusive seiner Struktur, das ist dann der zweite Schritt?
Genau, also dafür gibt es dann natürlich jetzt auch schon Verfahren und Beschreibungssprachen, also TEI haben wir ja gerade eben schon genannt. Das heißt also man müsste jetzt eigentlich dann mal schauen, wie bekomme ich beispielsweise jetzt TEI-Dateien entsprechend eigentlich jetzt in die Kataloge mit rein, dass ich die dann auch im Vollzugriff habe, das probieren wir jetzt auch gerade bei unseren eigenen digitalisierten Sammlungen, das vernünftig zu verknüpfen und diese Welten da zu verheiraten. Was aber auch wiederum nur ein Zwischenschritt ist, weil selbst die Volltexte sind dann eigentlich nur Brückentechnologie, würde ich sagen. Weil also dann habe ich zwar irgendwie Buchstaben und Zeichen, aber was bedeutet die denn eigentlich und was steht da eigentlich drin? Und das ist die Ebene, wo jetzt in den nächsten Jahren wirklich die Musik spielen wird. Das heißt also es fängt an mit der sogenannten Named-Entity-Recognition, NER. Was für Personen tauchen eigentlich in diesem Text auf oder was für Orte tauchen dort auf oder was für Institutionen oder was für Inhaltskonzepte werden dort diskutiert.
Wenn man sich das mal so ein bisschen in Aktion angucken möchte, wir haben eins unserer Portale ZEFYS, das ist unser Zeitungsportal, wo wir also Zeitungsartikel digitalisieren, und dort gibt es eine Unterdepandents über DDR-Zeitungen. Und die haben wir sowohl im Volltext durchsuchbar, also die drei großen Tageszeitungen der DDR im gesamten Erscheinungsverlauf, im Volltext durchsuchbar und durch Kooperation mit Externen, ich glaube Fraunhofer war es an der Stelle, auch zumindest teilweise schon mit Normdaten erschlossen. Das heißt also Personen, Themen, Institutionen und so weiter. Und dann hast du plötzlich die Möglichkeit zu gucken, okay ich muss nicht mehr im Vorhinein wissen, gerade bei Tageszeitungen, das ist ja ein riesiges Konvolut, wann, muss die nicht mehr irgendwie Tag für Tag durchblättern, wann wurde über Honeckers Rede XY eigentlich was geschrieben, sondern ich kann dann einfach mal danach suchen. Nämlich dann so ein Konzept wie, zeig mir alle Reden von Honecker raus.
Das klappt jetzt auch in dem Portal noch nicht so wirklich perfekt, aber es ist ein Schritt, der definitiv als nächstes kommen wird. Und das dann wiederum noch in einem klassischen OPAC abzubilden, würde ich sagen, das ist eigentlich ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Klassisches OPAC ist?
Also OPAC ist so das klassische Nachweisinstrument oder das Frontend einer bibliografischen Datenbank, in der ich halt normale Bibliotheksobjekte verwalte.
Also ein Public-Access-Catalogue. Ich muss diese ganzen Begriffe …
Ja das stimmt, da bin ich ein bisschen betriebsblind.
Dafür bin ich ja auch da. CEVIS zum Beispiel auch da muss man sich ja erst mal Gedanken machen. Schreibt sich ZEFYS, das Zeitungsinformationssystem, ja das sind wichtige Begriffe.
Da spielt halt die Musik. Gar nicht mal mehr im Volltext, sondern wirklich so in dem, was steht eigentlich in dem Volltext drin und wie kann ich mit dem eigentlich umgehen.
Also quasi auch eine semantische Beschreibung des Inhalts, dass man quasi rangeht und sagt, es git auch schon ein Grundverständnis, du bist nicht der erste Mensch, der auf dieses Ding blickt, sondern es ist schon mal gelesen worden und es ist auch schon mal verstanden worden und Dinge, die man daran verstehen kann und das, was ja meistens eigentlich erst mal auch die Basis des weiteren Verstehens ist, ist schon da. Orte zum Beispiel sehr schönes Beispiel. Warum soll man nicht eben auch Bücher und Inhalte über Orte suchen können und da muss man dann nicht irgendwie erst mal rausfinden, welches Berlin jetzt vielleicht gerade gemeint ist. Ob das jetzt unser Berlin ist oder irgend so ein Kaff in New Hampshire, wo irgendwelche Auswanderer auch nochmal ihr kleines Berlin gebaut haben, das sind ja wichtige Informationen. Und wenn die an der Stelle eben feststehen, ja dann stehen sie eben auch fest, und wenn sie feststehen, dann kann man sie auch festschreiben und das im Idealfall dann auch digital.
Wobei dann gerade bei Orten sind da wieder ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie scheußlich komplex dann die Welt halt sehr schnell wird, auch im Bereich der Metadaten. Weil Orte ändern plötzlich mal ihre Namen oder Orte splitten sich auf oder werden zusammengefasst und waren früher irgendwie Einzelkäffer und werden dann eingemeindet und werden dann plötzlich zu einem neuen Konstrukt. Dann ändern sich Sprachzuordnungen plötzlich und dann gibt es kein Sankt Petersburg mehr. Und das möchte ich auch alles irgendwie abbilden und auch dafür gibt es natürlich schon ganz gute Konzepte. Also zum Beispiel gibt es den sogenannten Getty-Thesaurus für Ortsnamen, der da schon vieles davon abfrühstückt. Aber da ist man auch wirklich auf einer Ebene, das möchte man auf gar keinen Fall mehr als Einzelbibliothek lösen, sondern das möchte man dann eigentlich gleich für die Welt™ irgendwie organisiert haben. Weil also da macht es keinen Sinn, dass da ein einzelnes Forschungsprojekt oder eine einzelne Institution anfängt, da irgendwelche Lösungen zu stricken, sondern so was geht dann nur kooperativ, aber das funktioniert auch hinreichend gut, würde ich sagen.
Um vielleicht nochmal kurz bei diesem Katalogisierungs- und Metadatenproblem auch zu bleiben, weil ich finde, das ist auch so ein bisschen der Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Es gibt ja noch ein  zweites großes, freies Projekt, was sich extrem mit der Metadataisierung der Welt auseinandersetzt, nämlich das Wikidata-Projekt von Wikipedia. Jetzt kann man ja die Bedeutung von Wikipedia glaube ich nicht ignorieren. Dementsprechend ist ja auch Wikidata – mir fiel es jetzt gerade ein, weil du sagtest so, Dinge ändern auch nach Zeit sozusagen ihre Bedeutung. Das sind das ja auch so Fragestellungen, die in das Wikidata-Projekt eingeflossen sind. Gibt es da Kontakt? Gibt es irgendwie einen Austausch zwischen diesen Welten?
Ja gibt es schon, aber das ist glaube ich so der Standardspruch dieser Folge hier, es ist kompliziert. Also mich persönlich hat das total elektrisiert. Ich kannte halt auch den Vorgänger schon, DBpedia. Den habe ich schon in ein paar Projekten benutzt, wo man ja dann über diese Sparkle-Endpoints dann auch schön seine Informationen sich maschinell rausziehen konnte. Grundsätzlich ist es schon, ich stelle immer diese provokante Frage gerne bei Vorträgen, die ich mache, warum haben Bibliotheken nicht die Wikipedia erfunden. Das wäre unser verdammter Job gewesen.
Ja das Wissen lag ja schon rum.
Das Wissen lag schon rum. Die Technologie dazu hat man als Informatiker an einem Wochenende zusammengetippt. Also Wikitechnologie war auch gut abgehangen. Klar dann die Details und irgendwie Diskussionsseite und so, Versionierung und so, aber trotzdem Wikitechnologie war ja schon da. Also Jimmy Wales hat ja jetzt nicht angefangen, Wiki zu erfinden.
Ja aber sie haben immerhin das erste Wiki erfunden, was sagen wir mal auch den Aufgaben gewachsen war, das muss man schon sagen. Das war also nicht nur eine kulturelle, sondern eben in Teilen auch eine technische Errungenschaft.
Ja Details. Also da würde ich jetzt wirklich sagen, okay im Bezug darauf, was sonst noch so programmiert wird, also die wesentliche Errungenschaft war die kulturelle an der Stelle. Und das ist etwas, wo ich wirklich es anprangere, dass Bibliotheken in solchen Fragestellungen zu wenig präsent sind.
Einfach auch, weil sie nicht diese kulturelle Flexibilität an der Stelle haben?
Ja, oder schon dann eben ein bisschen zu sehr in der Historie, also in der eigenen Vergangenheit dann vielleicht auch verortet sind. Also Wikipedia wurde von Bibliotheken schon in weiten Teilen genauso belächelt, wie irgendwie von der Restwissenschaft auch gerade auch. Also dieser Tipping-Point, wo dann plötzlich irgendwie Wikipedia besser war als die Enzyclopedia Britannica, das hat auch schon in den Bibliotheken ziemlich durchgeschockt. Also wir hatten damals eine relativ - gut, funktionär hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, …
They can’t just walk in.
An der SOB Göttingen wirklich selber arbeiten in Frank Schulenburg, der sitzt jetzt also in Kalifornien drüben und das war so lange bevor es so dieses Konzept irgendwie Residenz in Librarys gab von Wikipedia. So der war also wirklich gut und super vernetzt in der deutschen Wikipedia-Szene und war da glaube ich auch im Vorstand schon zu dem Zeitpunkt und er hat einen Arbeitsvertrag an der SOB Göttingen gehabt, und das hatte quasi auf die Restbibliothek null Impact. Da hätte man also eigentlich sonst was machen können. Das würde ich mir auch selber als persönliches Scheitern jederzeit ankreiden, dass ich mit dem zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht irgendwie viel mehr gemacht habe. Man war halt immer in seinem eigenen Trott und das war halt irgendwie was neues und was anderes und klar nachher ist man irgendwie immer schlauer. Aber ich sage, eigentlich müssen wir auch so was zumindest dann mal lernen. Also wenn wir uns jetzt solche Prozesse anschauen und sehen, okay hier wurde eine völlig neue Art erfunden, eigentlich Informationen zu sammeln und wie eigentlich Information strukturiert wird, und wie man damit umgeht. Und gerade Wikidata ist dann da wirklich die nächste sehr konsequente und tolle Entwicklung.
So was müssen doch Bibliotheken ganz zentral irgendwie mit gestalten und mitdenken, weil das machen wir seid tausenden von Jahren so. Wenn wir nicht irgendwie in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwinden wollen, weil wie gesagt Bestand selber wird uns nicht über die nächsten 20 Jahre bringen, auf gar keinen Fall, sondern wird eigentlich nur das Mitmachen und Mitdenken an solchen Strukturen, das wird uns retten. Warum programmieren wir keine Suchmaschinen? Wenn ich jetzt mir so Suchmaschinentechnologie angucke, Solar oder Elastic Search, was so die großen OpenSource-Entwicklungen im Bereich der Suchmaschinen sind, die müssen doch von Bibliotheken erfunden werden und eben nicht von entweder motivierten Einzelpersonen oder Firmen oder Google oder dem militärisch-industriellen Komplex, sondern das müssen Bibliotheken eigentlich machen. So und davon sind wir aber leider noch ziemlich entfernt.
Was heißt denn das? Also ich meine, heißt das, dass die beiden Projekte sich nach wie vor komplett getrennt entwickeln oder ist da nicht einfach … mehr Potential? Also man muss ja dazu sagen für die Leute, denen auch Wikidata als Projekt jetzt noch nicht so bekannt ist, im Prinzip ist es ja so eine Auskopplung aus den normalen Wikipedia-Dingern. Und so ein bisschen wie die Formate, die du vorhin gerade beschrieben hast, so dieses METS, wo du sagst, naja es gibt so Bücher, die haben so Seiten und wir haben das jetzt mal mit der Nummerierung und mit dem Umfang und so weiter und vielleicht auch noch mit dem Titel und dem Autor irgendwie umfasst. Wir beschreiben sozusagen das was da ist. Und genauso ist es so ein bisschen auch bei Wikidata gewesen, dass man einfach gesagt hat, wir haben jetzt diese Artikelflut, das heißt wir haben überhaupt erst mal eine Basis von „wir wissen, welche Dinge überhaupt beschreibenswürdig sind“ und das macht sie quasi dann auch unterscheidungswürdig und mit diesem Metadaten-System wird quasi erst mal eine Struktur, also ein Gerüst geschaffen, wo man sagt, jetzt können wir die Dinger auch auseinanderhalten.
Jetzt wissen wir irgendwie, das eine Berlin und das andere Berlin hat nichts miteinander zu tun, vielleicht hat es was miteinander zu tun auf einer weiteren Ebene und sogar das kriegen wir dann irgendwann nochmal abgebildet. Und jetzt hat sich aus diesem Prozess in den letzten Jahren sagen wir mal ein System entwickelt, was jetzt eben anfängt, so seinen eigenen Datenrausch zu erleben. So wie am Anfang mit der Wikipedia diesen enormen Zuwachs an Artikeln hatten, irgendwann war dann, nicht alles, aber so viel beschrieben, dass jetzt die interne Dynamik sich dort ändert. Sehr viel mehr ist Pflege, Änderung, Updates, etc. Klar es kommen neue Sachen dazu, aber die Zahl der neuen Sachen, die dazukommen ist nicht so groß. Im Wikidata-Bereich wiederum ist es irgendwie genau andersrum. Nachdem man sich da erst mal sanft vor sich hin initialisiert hat, bricht das Ganze jetzt erst in so einen richtigen Wahnsinn aus.
Also der Versuch einer 2-Schritt-Antwort darauf. Also erst mal ist es ja nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie aneinander vorbeiläuft oder man nichts voneinander weiß oder das nicht schon miteinander nutzt. Also beispielsweise das worüber wir hier gerade sprechen, nämlich welche Person ist es eigentlich und welcher Ort ist es, da hatten wir schon gesagt, das sind eigentlich Normdaten, die also normiert sind, und die eben irgendwo klar ein Objekt eineindeutig bezeichnen. So und da gibt es eigentlich seit vielen vielen Jahren eine Kooperation zwischen Wikipedia und der deutschen Nationalbibliothek. Die hatten wir schon mal ganz am Anfang erwähnt, in Frankfurt sitzend. Dass die nämlich dort die sogenannte GND nutzen, Wikipedia nutzt dort Bibliotheksdaten. GND das ist die gemeinsame ist die gemeinsame Normdatendatei.
Gemeinsame Normdatei.
Sehr gut, hervorgegangen damals aus zwei unterschiedlichen Quellen, nämlich der SWS war das, Schlagwort-Normdatei und den PND, der Personen-Normdatei, also Personen und Institutionen waren in der einen Domäne definiert und Schlagworte in der anderen. Und das hat man dann vor, ach Gott das ist auch schon alles viele viele Jahre her, 8-10 Jahre her, zusammengeführt in der GND. Und das ist jetzt auch eine gut computerlesbare Datenquelle, um quasi sämtliche in Deutschland bekannten Normdaten im Bereich des Bibliothekswesens, was jetzt so diese einfache Publikationsebene angeht zumindest, beschreiben und darauf zugreifen zu können. Die grundsätzliche Spielregel ist hier schonmal, jeder, der in Deutschland irgendwas publiziert hat und dann auch irgendwie Objekt mit einer eigenen ISBN-, ISSN-Nummer hat und sein Exemplardatensatz bei der GND abgelegt hat, der kommt als Person in diese Normdatendatei auch rein.
Also ich beispielsweise habe ja auch ein paar Publikationen, für mich gibt es da einen Eintrag und dann kann man nachgucken, was hat der eigentlich publiziert? Das heißt also, wenn man sich natürlich jetzt das anguckt, da sind jetzt also viele viele viele hunderttausende wichtige Personen drin modelliert. Aber die Grundvoraussetzung ist halt, sie muss was publiziert haben irgendwann mal. Es gibt noch andere Wege, wie man da reinkommt, aber das ist erst mal so der Preset. Und das ist natürlich jetzt ein wichtiger Bestandteil von dem, was Wikipedia interessiert, aber natürlich interessiert die auch noch andere Dinge. Also sprich jetzt irgendwie ein Popmusiker was weiß ich, der jetzt also irgendwo natürlich nie irgendwie wissenschaftlich gearbeitet hat, muss ja trotzdem in der Wikipedia beschrieben werden, dann habe ich eventuell keinen GND-Eintrag. Und dann ist immer die Frage, legt man dafür jetzt trotzdem einen GND-Eintrag an, weil es letztendlich auch gleichzeitig ein Schlagwort ist. Weil da wird dann über Udo Lindenberg publiziert und dann möchte ich Udo Lindenberg schon als Entität drin haben, auch wenn er selber nicht publiziert hat. Und solche Prozesse werden dann dort abgehandelt. Aber das findet alles statt und das passiert.
Das heißt also, du findest bei vielen vielen Wikipedia-Artikeln ganz unten auf der Seite dann einen direkten Link in die GND rein. So wo du dann auch gucken kannst, okay wie sieht es dort in dieser Ebene aus. Das wird auch bei Wikidata weitergenutzt. Dann ist natürlich noch die Frage, jetzt kommt der zweite Teil der Antwort, ist es dann schon kompliziert, weil natürlich so die Arbeitsweisen dieser beiden Welten schon doch sehr unterschiedlich sind. Das heißt also, im Bibliothekswesen geht es eigentlich immer darum, Dinge zu standardisieren und irgendwie in einen vernünftigen Geschäftsgang zu transformieren. Du willst als Bibliothek eigentlich immer nie Sonderfälle bearbeiten, sondern immer, wenn ein Sonderfall kommt, möchtest du deine Grundregeln so erweitern, dass der mit abgedeckt ist und wenn doch mal was ähnliches kommt, dass es dann wieder standardisiert durchlaufen kann. Das ist so eine Grunddenke von Bibliotheken.
Das heißt also du hast immer irgendwie eine Betriebsanleitung, eine Anweisung und nach der läuft etwas ab. Ein Geschäftsgang halt, ein klassischer. So und bei Wikidata ist es schon ein bisschen anders, das kommt ja eben wirklich aus dieser Wikipedia-Philosophie, da macht man halt, wenn man gerade Zeit hat und wenn man gerade Lust hat und so wie man es gerade irgendwie vernünftig findet und dann diskutiert man darüber. Diskutieren willst du in Bibliotheken eigentlich nicht, sondern da willst du nachgucken, wie ist es im Regelwerk hinterlegt und dann machst du es so. Dann kann man noch drüber diskutieren, ob das Regelwerk richtig ausgelegt wurde oder nicht. Und das führt dann schon zu durchaus kulturell interessanten Situationen, um es mal so zu sagen. Wir hatten beispielsweise mal …
Kurze Nachfrage, wer diskutiert worüber?
Innerhalb der Wikipedia, also Wikipedia Diskussionsseite kann man sich ja beliebig angucken, was da los ist.
Aber das ist bei Wikidata schon nochmal ein anderes kulturelles Konstrukt.
Ja schon, aber so der Grundmindset ist da schon ein bisschen ein anderer. Also das konkrete Beispiele, was ich bringen würde, war, wir haben auch noch zur Göttinger Zeit, also ich noch in Göttingen war, versucht, mal unsere wissenschaftlichen Sammlungen nach Wikidata reinzubringen. Das heißt also wissenschaftliche Sammlungen, da ging es um Objekte, was weiß ich, also irgendwie ein medizinisches kriminal-medizinische Sammlung, wo also irgendwie die Gehirne von Mördern in Formaldehyd irgendwo in Regalen drin standen. Oder Meteoriten waren es glaube ich dann auch, hatten wir da viel in Göttingen, was irgendwer gesammelt hatte. Und da ging es einfach nur darum, nicht die einzelnen Objekte in Wikidata reinzubringen, also nicht das einzelne Mörderhirn oder den einzelnen Meteoriten, sondern nur die grundsätzliche Information darüber, es gibt an der Universität Göttingen eine Sammlung, die im medizinischen Bereich angesiedelt ist, mit einem Schwerpunkt irgendwie Kriminalhistorie, was auch immer.
Da gibt es eine Sammlung und da gibt es einen Kustos, den kann man irgendwie ansprechen und da ist die Adresse und da erfahrt ihr mehr. Und da ist vielleicht noch eine Homepage. Diese auch sehr Metainformation wollten wir in Wikidata reinbringen. Dann hatten wir Kooperationen und das dann aber halt zu hunderten oder tausenden von Sammlungen, damit man irgendwo mal einen Ort hat, an dem man nachgucken kann, welche Sammlung gibt es überhaupt? Und wir hatten dann glaube ich drei Treffen mit den Leuten von Wikidata und die liefen alle irgendwie ein bisschen sperrig. Weil die also – wir hatten natürlich ein Interesse daran, so das ist jetzt diese Liste von 400 Sammlungen, die wollen wir da reinbringen. Wir haben selber die Leute, nämlich Bibliothekare, die das machen können, wir stellen auch die Manpower. Wir wissen, wie es geht, ist das okay für euch? Und dann fingen die schon an, irgendwie sehr rumzulavieren, nach dem Motto, naja könnt ihr schon machen, jetzt etwas zugespitzt, aber es kann halt auch passieren, dass es fünf Minuten später wieder gelöscht wird.
Ganz so extrem haben sie es nicht gesagt, aber eigentlich schon. Weil ist halt …
Relevanzdiskussion.
Relevanzdiskussion. Und wo wir dann sagen, ja okay, aber wir sind nunmal irgendwie so als Bibliotheken doch so ziemlich die vertrauenswürdigsten Institutionen in Sachen Relevanzmessung, die man sich vielleicht irgendwie so vorstellen kann, das machen wir hier seit ein paar hundert Jahren und wenn wir jetzt dafür geradestehen, dass diese 400 Sammlungen wirklich existieren und da sind, dann hätten wir schon ganz gerne eine Sicherheit, dass die nicht in fünf Minuten wieder gelöscht werden. Und die wollte man uns nicht geben, diese Sicherheit. Kann halt passieren, wenn dann irgendjemand halt daher kommt und sagt, naja …, dann hat er auch die Werkzeuge. Und damit können wiederum dann Bibliotheken dann ganz schwer umgehen.
Verstehe ich.
Weil die möchten nun doch die Deutungshoheit darüber haben, was quasi relevant ist, weil das ist halt ihr Selbstverständnis. Ich habe dann ziemlich den Kontakt verloren, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie es weitergeht. Bestimmt haben sich alle geeinigt und liegen sich jetzt weinend in den Armen und alles ist total flauschig. Ich habe das wirklich lange nicht mehr nachvollzogen. Aber das war für mich schon so ein Moment, wo ich gemerkt habe, okay die wollen definitiv beide das gleiche, aber es sind dann eben schon etwas kulturelle Unterschiede, die da am Start sind. Ähnlich wie ich das vorhin zu den Wissenschaftlern und dem klandestinen Verhalten definiert habe. Bibliotheken sind da schon ein bisschen speziell unterwegs, was so was angeht.
Jetzt haben wir schon viel gesprochen über die Datenakquise, wie kommt man denn überhaupt ran, welchen Informationen und Quellen wenden sich Bibliotheken eigentlich zu? Und wenn man das dann getan hat, welche Maßnahmen werden ergriffen, um all das zu erschließen, zu katalogisieren, zugänglich zu machen? Ist damit so die Fragestellung des „wie organisiert man denn diese Verfügbarmachung“ konkret auch schon behandelt? Weil zunächst einmal sind das ja alles Werkzeuge quasi innerhalb der Bibliothek oder innerhalb der Wissenschaftler, die daran arbeiten. Das sind ja jetzt nicht unbedingt die Formate, in denen man das dann so in die Öffentlichkeit reinbringt. Und in dem Moment, wo eine Bibliothek ja dieses Selbstverständnis des „wir sammeln nicht nur die Information als Selbstzweck, sondern wir wollen sie ja auch zugänglich machen“, muss man sich ja auch darüber Gedanken machen, wie machen wir das?
Und wenn man einerseits schöne Lesesäle hat, die auch das eine oder andere Mal einem Spielfilm einen schönen Hintergrund bieten können, ist das natürlich dann auch in Zeiten der Vernetzung eine Frage, wie geht es raus, wie kommt man da überhaupt ran? Was für Fragestellungen habt ihr euch da gestellt?
Ja gucken, wie kann man jetzt die Sachen so ein bisschen strukturieren. Also grundsätzlich was so als Grundfilter über dem Ganzen liegt ist erst mal schon die Rechtefrage. Die kann man glaube ich an der Stelle leider jetzt im Jahr 2017 noch nicht ganz ausblenden. Das heißt also, wenn ich einen Lesesaal habe und ich habe ein gekauftes Buch, das ich also erworben habe und katalogisiert habe und das steht da entweder in der Freihandaufstellung oder es wird mir aus dem Magazin hochgeliefert und ich habe meinen Nutzer und der hat es sich ausgeliehen und der liest es an seinem Tisch und gibt es dann zurück, ist einfach mal alles schick. Da kann also wenig schiefgehen, wenn er das nicht irgendwie versucht zu klauen oder so.
Wenn er nicht seinen mobilen Scanner dabei gehabt hat.
Ja was soweit erst mal vielleicht auch okay wäre. Schlimmer wäre, wenn er da halt anfängt drin rumzuschreiben und Eselsohren reinmacht und Wasser drüber schüttet, wenn es denn nur Wasser ist. Im Digitalen ist die Sache halt alles ein bisschen schwieriger. So das heißt also, was immerhin schon mal völlig unstrittig ist, etwa anders als bei Museen, ist, dass schon mal alle Metadaten frei sind in Bibliotheken. Das ist ganz ganz breiter Konsens. All das, was wir im Bereich eben der Erschließung mit den ganzen Normdaten und den ganzen sonstigen Metadaten beschrieben haben, die geben wir immer und ausschließlich frei und umsonst zu jeglicher Nachnutzung nach draußen. Das heißt also public domain. Jetzt noch nicht mal creative commons oder so was und irgendwie nennt uns, wenn ihr die nutzt, sondern Bibliotheksmetadaten sind per Definition immer frei. Das ist schon mal ein ganz wichtiges Statement, das ist anders als bei Museen. Die beispielsweise argumentieren, in unseren Museumsmetadaten da stehen beispielsweise wirklich wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse über Provinienzforschung drin.
Wann ist dieses Objekt von wem, wo bei einer Auktion erworben worden und dann restauriert und so weiter, da hat ein Wissenschaftler ein halbes Jahr dran gearbeitet, das steht jetzt in den Metadaten drin, darum können wir diese Metadaten nicht rausgeben, denn das ist irgendwie quasi wissenschaftlich schützenswert. Das ist bei Bibliotheken nicht so. Bei den Inhalten ist es halt wirklich dann schwieriger. Hatte ich gerade eben gesagt, unproblematisch 70 Jahre nach Tod des Autors, das heißt also die Sachen sind dann eigentlich per Definition public domain, auch der Vorgang des Digitalisierens schafft dort meiner Meinung nach kein neues Urheberrecht irgendwo, also keinen neuen Schutzbereich. Darüber wird viel diskutiert in der Bibliotheksszene, ich habe da eine sehr klare, vielleicht auch radikale, Meinung. Aber es wird halt immer gesagt, naja wir können jetzt nicht Beethovens 9. in voller Qualität ins Netz stellen, weil dann kommen irgendwelche Verlage und machen einen Reprint und irgendjemand druckt da Poster draus oder sonst was,
Da würde ich sagen, super.
Das ist doch prima.
Und wenn schon.
Darum geht es doch eigentlich.
Weil das ist nunmal gemeinfrei. Aber da tickt dann in manchen Köpfen dann doch noch immer so im Hintergrund mit, naja es ist ja auch irgendwie unser Kulturgut, es ist in unserem Bestand, wir haben es gesammelt, wir haben es gepflegt all die Jahrhundert.
Und jetzt ist es unsers.
Und auch die digitale Fassung soll noch irgendwie unsers bleiben. Und vielleicht können wir auch noch irgendwie ein paar Euro rausholen.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen dieser Museumsgedanke. Jetzt haben wir dieses teure alte Bild hier hingehängt, jetzt darf das auch keiner fotografieren, weil wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Ja bei Museen sehe ich es wiederum ein bisschen anders, weil dort dann beispielsweise dann die Kreativrechte eines Fotografen durchaus eine Rolle spielen können. Das heißt also, wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein 3D-Objekt hast, eine Büste oder ähnliches und er das Licht setzt und sich die Perspektive überlegt und dann also wirklich das eine geniale Bild macht, dann entsteht dann schon so etwas wie ein neues Urheberrecht, nämlich von ihm als Künstler quasi.
Aber nur an diesem einen Bild.
An diesem einen Bild. Und bei Bibliotheken ist es aber eigentlich juristisch, das habe ich auch mit Armin Talke, der hat da einen sehr schönen Aufsatz zu geschrieben, das ist quasi mein Haus- und Hofjurist an der Stabi. Für den Bibliotheksbereich muss man eigentlich nur eine ganz einfache Frage klären. Nämlich wenn man in einer perfekten Welt leben würde und den perfekten Buchscanner hat, wenn ich dasselbe Buch dann zweimal durch diese Maschine durchlaufen lasse, kommen dann identische Bilder raus oder sind die Bilder unterschiedlich. Und man würde sagen, in einer perfekten Welt kommt immer dasselbe Bild raus, das nämlich perfekt quasi den Inhalt reproduziert. Das bedeutet aber im Umkehrschluss, dass ich eigentlich jede Art von Kreativität oder von irgendwie künstlerischem Anspruch eliminieren möchte aus dieser Scankette. Ich möchte eben gerade, dass es immer gleich aussieht, dass es möglichst dicht am Original ist. Ich möchte da keine Interpretation haben des Objektes. Und damit hat man eigentlich schon sehr schnell die Antwort gefunden, ob durch ein Scan neues Urheberrecht entsteht oder nicht.
Wenn man eigentlich möchte, dass es immer gleich aussieht und dass es immer perfekt aussieht, kann kein Urheberrecht daran entstanden. Und darum bin ich also der Meinung, was immer 70 Jahre nach Tod des Autors digitalisiert wird in Form von Flachwaren und Buchscannern ist natürlich public domain und da können wir noch nicht mal creative commons dransetzen. Weil noch nicht mal dafür haben wir die Rechte. Aber das ist sicherlich nicht unbedingt die Mehrheitsmeinung innerhalb des deutschen Bibliothekswesens, die ich hier vertrete.
Sind denn Kunstwerke als solche auch ein Thema für das Bibliothekswesen? Also ist das auch im Fokus?
Schon ja. Wenn es zu dem jeweiligen Sammlungsstrategie passt, dann schon. Also wir hatten in Göttingen beispielsweise eine Portätsammlung. Haben wir in Berlin auch eine Portätsammlung, weiß ich nicht. Aber wenn man sich jetzt beispielsweise im CrossAsia-Portal mal umtreibt, wo wir also unsere ganzen asiatischen Materialien haben, da gibt es ganz ganz wundervolle Stiche beispielsweise. Also wundervolle Kunstwerke. Im Bereich der Kartenabteilung, haben eine große renommierte Kartenabteilung in der Stabi, da sind sicherlich auch ästhetisch ausgesprochen interessante Sachen drin zu finden. Bis hin zu 3D-Objekten. Die Kartenabteilung hat beispielsweise auch eine ganz interessante Globensammlung, durch die kann man auch durchlaufen. Ein Teil davon ist auch im Lesesaal ausgestellt. Wo du also gucken kannst, wie also durch die Jahrhundert, naja so viele Jahrhunderte sind es ja noch nicht, seit die Erde rund ist, aber wie also Globen letztendlich einfach gebaut worden sind und was die wie repräsentiert haben an Informationsschichten und ähnliches. Das spielt schon eine Rolle. Sind nicht nur Flachwaren und Handschriften.
Ja und findet man dann auch die von dir vorhin genannte Büste sozusagen auch schon im perfekten 3D-Scan, die man dann in seinem eigenen Heim 3D-Drucker mal eben heruntergeladen und nachgedruckt hat?
Also ein Projekt, das wir jetzt gerade gestartet haben, ist in der Tat, Kinderbücher zu scannen und zwar 3D-Kinderbücher. Das heißt also …
So mit Fühllöchern und so zum aufklappen?
So Aufklappgeschichten und so was ja. Das ist schon eine ganz faszinierende Herausforderung, vor der man dann plötzlich steht. Das heißt also, du hast dann so ein Aufklappteil, wo dann also das von außen erst mal wie ein normales Buch aussieht, und dann klappst du es auf und durch die sehr clevere Falt- und …
Kommen dann auf einmal so Dinosaurier raus.
Kommen dir Dinosaurier entgegen oder Moby Dick oder was auch immer und dann hast du noch so ein paar Laschen, an denen kannst du ziehen und dann bewegen sich Dinge und so was. Und das versuchen wir jetzt, quasi als ein perfektes 3D-Modell zu digitalisieren, und zwar so, dass es auch seine Funktion erhält. Das heißt also, dass ich nicht nur jetzt einen Endzustand habe, den ich drehen kann, sondern dass ich also auch den ganzen Prozess des Auf- und Zuklappens vernünftig modellieren plus aller spielerisch sinnvollen Freiheitsgrade. Das heißt also, wenn da eben eine Zuglasche ist, an der sich dann irgendwelche Figuren bewegen oder ähnliches oder was auf oder zugedeckt oder -geklappt wird, dass auch das funktioniert online. Das beutetet letztendlich, du kommst mit normalen Scanverfahren oder 3D-Verfahren da gar nicht weiter, sondern du musst eine wirkliche 3D-Modellierung machen. Und unser derzeitiger Ansatz wird sein, …
Aber nicht nur das, auch eine mechanische Beschreibung quasi so ein Bewegungs…
Genau, du musst die Physik, du musst Reibung abbilden, du musst Drehmomente und so weiter irgendwo mit drin haben. Und unser derzeitiger Ansatz ist, das über eine Gaming-Engine zu machen. Das heißt also zu sagen, man nimmt so eine 3D-Engine von Quake oder was auch immer, wo Physik ja auch schon  ganz gut drin modelliert ist und baut dort dann einfach Stück für Stück die Materialität von Pappe beispielsweise einigermaßen nach, so dass es hinterher in etwa sich so anfüllt wie das Original. Und klebt dann eigentlich am Ende nur auf die 3D-Objekte die entsprechenden Scans oder Fotos dann drauf. Und hat dann also wirklich das Ganze möglichst exakt nachgebastelt, so dass man es dann auch online nachvollziehen kann. Das wird spannend, ob das gelingt.
Ja das ist sehr spannend. Vor allem fällt mir in dem Zusammenhang auch ein, und auch da kann ich jetzt mal wieder – das mache ich ja immer am liebsten – eine alte Forschergeistfolge auch nochmal …
Das Archiv ist schon recht umfänglich.
Ja das ist ja dann der Vorteil. Also umso mehr man da zusammengetragen hat, umso mehr kommt dabei raus. Jetzt muss ich es bloß gerade nochmal finden. Was ich meine ist, es ließe sich ja dann mit so einem Ansatz ließen sich ja dann auch Experimentsituationen auch beschreiben.
Ja.
Die ja so ein grundsätzliches Problem darstellen in der Wissenschaft. Es wird halt geforscht, es wird publiziert. Ab und zu geht dann mal jemand los und sagt, ich überprüfe das jetzt mal. Und dann so, sorry, aber ich konnte allein diesen experimentellen Aufbau schon gar nicht mehr bauen, einerseits weil natürlich Geräte nicht mehr existieren, Software nicht Teil des Archivierungsprozesses war oder eben auch nur die Aufbaubeschreibung von allem komplex oder unzureichend war oder Materialien verwendet wurden, die nicht so ohne weiteres zu finden sind. Und das sind alles so auch Aspekte der Archivierung, wo an der Stelle vielleicht auch die wissenschaftliche Arbeit und das Bibliothekswesen nochmal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise zusammenkommen kann.
Die Reliabilität ist nicht gegeben, wenn ich mich an mein sozialwissenschaftliches Studium richtig erinnere. Ja ich kann dasselbe Experimente nicht nochmal genauso nachvollziehen.
Kurz noch die Sendung, auf die ich mich beziehe, ist Forschergeist 27 mit Ulrich Dirnagl, Vertrauen und Kontrolle in der Wissenschaft. Wo zwar mit der spezifischen Perspektive Medizin da drauf geblickt wird, aber das eben ein Thema war.
Da mach ich da gleich noch eine Fußnote dran, was nämlich dann wirklich auch ein durchaus mittelzentrales Bibliotheksthema ist, Archivierung von Forschungsdaten. Das ist durchaus ein Thema in der Szene. Das heißt also nicht nur zu sagen, wir kümmern uns um die Publikationen und dort um die Langzeitarchivierung, dass das alles irgendwie erhalten bleibt, sondern auch wirklich um alles, was im Forschungsprozess selber an Primärdaten entsteht.
Messdaten?
Sensordaten, was auch immer. Und dort sind Bibliotheken durchaus auch aktiv, dann meistens im Zusammenhang mit Rechenzentren, weil die Volumina, von denen wir da reden, sind dann schon irgendwie sehr schon im Terra- und Petabytebereich, da muss man schon ein einigermaßen zünftiges Rechenzentrum dafür am Start haben, damit man das irgendwie noch unter Kontrolle hat, aber auch das spielt dann da mit rein für die Reliabilität.
Jetzt haben wir wieder so eine Klammer geöffnet. Meine eigentliche Frage ging ja so, wie macht man das jetzt alles verfügbar? Jetzt haben wir nochmal einige Beispiele nachgeliefert, was man alles noch sammeln und katalogisieren und darstellen kann, aber letztlich ist natürlich genau diese Darstellung dann auch die Basis, auf der man dann eben so eine, wie macht man das jetzt zugänglich, einerseits auf einer rechtlichen Ebene, andererseits auf einer technischen Ebene, was zeichnet sich da gerade ab?
Also ich würde sagen, hier muss man nochmal unterscheiden zwischen Maschinen als Kunden und Menschen als Kunden. Womit wollen wir anfangen, was interessiert dich mehr? Weil es dauert jeweils lange.
Erst mal die Menschen. Ich denke mal, der Maschinenteil könnte noch ein bisschen weiter führen.
Okay, also bei Menschen denke ich das ist eine Sache, die mich persönlich immer ein bisschen schmerzt. Wir hatten gerade eben über die Lesesäle schon gesprochen. Bibliotheken haben eine ganz ganz lange Tradition darin, eine sehr elaborierte ausgestellte Ästhetik zu haben in ihren Räumlichkeiten. Das heißt also, egal in welcher Kultur du eigentlich unterwegs bist, egal in welchem Jahrhundert du unterwegs bist, Bibliotheksbauten und die Art und Weise, wie quasi die Benutzung von Bibliotheken ästhetisch und von der Usability her gedacht ist, ist ausgesprochen pfiffig. Das ist also einfach immer tolle Architektur. Also Bibliotheksbau ist immer auch eine Prestigeangelegenheit.
Und gehört aber auch wirklich zu den beeindruckendsten Beispielen von Architektur generell. Also immer wenn man sich mal so tolle Filme oder Fotos von Gebäuden anschaut, Bibliotheken sind immer ganz weit vorn.
Die sind ganz weit vorne ganz genau. Das hört immer sehr schnell übrigens auf, wenn man in die Mitarbeitertrakt wechselt. Da ist auch die Stabi, da hast du also wirklich nur noch Sichtbeton und alles nur noch so semischön. Das ist auch bei Neubauten leider so.
Ja auch so ein Fehler.
Aber worauf ich hinaus will, es gibt überhaupt keine Entsprechung dafür im digitalen Bereich. Das heißt also, das was ich eigentlich auch seit Tag 0, seit ich an der Bibliothek bin, das ist seit 2005, 12 Jahren, jetzt anprangere, ist, warum haben wir eigentlich dieses ästhetische Empfinden für Bibliotheken nie in den digitalen Bereich mal rübergerettet?
Weil man dann so auf die entsprechenden Portale kommt, dann ist das so ein bisschen wie Sichtbeton.
Das ist im Zweifel noch ein bisschen schlimmer auch. Und ich meine jetzt nicht, warum verbauen wir da keinen Stuck, und warum machen wir hier nicht noch ein Röschen und dort noch einen Lichtschacht. Aber warum ist uns das so wenig wert auf der anderen Seite?
Warum macht man sich da keine Gedanken über das Onboarding sozusagen, dieses, wie begegne ich diesem Wissen?
Und zwar sowohl was ästhetisch angeht, als auch was jetzt User Experience im Allgemeinen angeht. Also die Art und Weise, wie bedient sich das Ganze, wie fühlt sich das eigentlich an? Und da könnte man jetzt auch lange durch die Historie durchgehen von diesen OPAC-Systemen, also die klassischen Bibliothekskataloge, war schon die Rede, die sind halt hocheffizient, die tun das halt schon sehr gut. Nämlich dass ich komplizierte Expertensuchen, Queries abgegeben kann, wo ich aber auch eine Syntax dafür lernen muss und die kennen muss.
Aber es hat so die Ästhetik einer Buchhaltungssoftware?
Aber es hat die Ästhetik einer Buchhaltungssoftware, ganz genau. Viel mehr passiert da nicht so. Und das ist auch maximal weit weg von so der Nutzererfahrung, wenn ich vor so einem Bibliotheksregal eigentlich stehe. Also das kenne ich auch noch aus dem Studium, diesen Moment dieser Zufallsfunde. Du stehst vor einem Regal, du hast eigentlich in der Regel deine Signatur von dem Buch und den Standort von dem Buch rausgesucht und guckst noch so ein bisschen links und guckst noch ein bisschen rechts und plötzlich findest du noch 2-3 andere Bücher, die eigentlich auch ganz spannend sind, die du überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm hattest, die aber dein Forschungsthema noch unter einem interessanten anderen Winkel beleuchten, dann nimmst du die halt mit raus. Das ist also dieses Zufallsfund machen können. Es gibt auch einen schönen Fachbegriff, den ich leider immer wieder vergesse, wie man Nutzeroberflächen so baut, dass das ermöglicht und befördert wird. Auch so eine Erfahrung …
Sexy?
Also auch so eine Erfahrung irgendwie in den digitalen Raum rüberzuretten, da gibt es auch keinen echten Sinn für. Damit meine ich jetzt nicht solche Mechanismen wie bei Amazon, Leute, die dieses Buch gekauft haben, haben auch diese fünf Bücher gekauft. Das wurde durchaus auch probiert, und kam aber im OPAC-Wesen nicht wirklich gut an, das hat dann nicht so rasend gut funktioniert das Ganze. Also die Ästhetik unserer ganzen Nutzeroberflächen ist irgendwie so wahnsinnig verbesserungswürdig. Und das fängt dann auch wirklich so mit Personalausstattung an. Wir haben an der Stabi 850 Kolleginnen und Kollegen insgesamt und davon Anzahl der dezidiert digitalen Mediengestalter 0.
Das ist so ein bisschen … da geht noch was.
Ich denke auch, da sollte noch was gehen. So und das ist an anderen Bibliotheken nicht anders. Wir haben jetzt immerhin schon mal den Punkt, dass wir wirklich viele sehr fähige Informatiker haben und die sind im Zweifelsfall dann schon nochmal wichtiger vielleicht als die Mediengestalter, aber trotzdem.
Aber sie stehen ja jetzt nicht unbedingt im Ruf, im Bereich Userinterfaces und Userexperience gleich alle Lösungen zu haben.
Ganz genau. Das ist also auch so neben dem, warum haben wir Wikipedia nicht erfunden, das zweite ist so meiner Grundclaims, die ich versuche, immer unterzubringen, wir müssen uns viel viel mehr um Usabiliity und auch um Ästhetik von Informationen eigentlich kümmern. Um dort irgendwie so diese ganzen Funde, die wir da aus der Analogwelt eigentlich seit Jahrhunderten vor uns hertragen, das müssen wir einfach mal ernsthafter auch im Digitalen angehen. So und das geht dann eben auch wirklich in die Bedienung runter. Das heißt also, wie bedienen sich eigentlich Trefferlisten beispielsweise? Und wie komme ich dann von einer Trefferliste auf eine Einzelansicht? Und wissen die Leute überhaupt noch wo sie sind oder sind sie schon wieder irgendwie verloren?
Und warum ist alles, was ich eingegeben habe, gleich wieder weg, wenn ich irgendwie auf den falschen Button gedrückt habe?
Oder warum funktioniert der Zurück-Button nicht? Oder warum werden mir überhaupt Sachen angezeigt, die ich hier gerade suche? Das ist zum Beispiel ein Thema bei unseren digitalisierten Sammlungen, wo ich mit meinen Kollegen viel drüber nachdenke. Wenn ich also irgendeinen Suchbegriff reingebe und ich bekomme eine Trefferliste, kann ich nachvollziehen warum jeder einzelne Treffer mir eigentlich da gerade angezeigt wird? Und das fängt dann so an – wir hatten jetzt schon über die verschiedenen Arten von Metadaten gesprochen – wenn der Suchbegriff, den ich eingetippt habe, im Titel auch vorhanden ist, dann wird der bei uns jetzt gelb hervorgehoben im Titel. Wenn jetzt aber ein Treffer zustande gekommen ist, weil irgendwo in den Volltexten, die wir da schon haben, getroffen ist, wird dann auch ein Volltextsnippet angezeigt und auch dort gelb hinterlegt. Aber wo wir beispielsweise noch nicht sind ist, wenn es jetzt in irgendwelchen versteckten anderen bibliografischen Metadaten der Fall ist, die wir normalerweise in der Trefferliste nicht anzeigen würden, beispielsweise jetzt was weiß ich Schlagwort XY, blenden wir normalerweise aus, ist gar nicht so zentrale Information.
Oder wurde mal woanders kommentiert von einer anderen Person/Information
Wie auch immer genau. Aber wenn jetzt dieser Treffer genau deshalb jetzt durch meine Suche mir angezeigt wird, möchte ich da eigentlich gerne eine Ausnahme definieren, okay zeige immer auch das Metadatenelement an, auf dem jetzt hier gerade gefunden wurde, damit die Leute wissen, wieso zeigst du mir das überhaupt? Das ist so ein Grundsetting, das irgendwie mal konsequent zu Ende zu denken. Solche Sachen finde ich wahnsinnig wichtig. Weil wir kleben irgendwie seit 10 Jahren daran, was macht Google? Und da wieder dieser Punkt, ja vielleicht hätten wir auch Google erfinden müssen. Google hat einfach mal sehr viele sehr unterschiedliche Interessen und ich bin so glaube ich doch immer recht weit weg vom Google-Bashing, aber eine Bibliothekssuche die darf auch mal anders oder auch vor allen Dingen besser funktionieren als eine Google-Standardsuche, die einfach noch ganz ganz Trillionen anderer Usecases abdecken muss.
Wie heißt denn dann das Google von Bibliothek? Bible?
Ja und auch Google-Books.
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Und ich denke, es ist auch sinnvoll, von dem auszugehen, was diese Bibliotheken auch schon sich jetzt quasi über Jahrhunderte erarbeitet haben. Also das wäre jetzt sagen wir mal mein intuitiver Ansatz, dass ich mir denke, ja okay wie würde ich denn digital auf dieses Wissen zugehen? Dann versetze ich mich einfach mal wieder in die Wim Wenders Perspektive und geh halt einfach in diesen Saal rein und da habe ich ja im Prinzip schon eine vollständige Onboarding-Experience, wie man das heutzutage sagen kann so. Ich weiß sofort, an wen ich mich wenden soll. Ich weiß dann auch in etwa, wie ich meine Fragen formuliere und ich weiß auch in etwa, wie ich die Ergebnisse präsentiert bekomme. Und um dieses Metadatenbeispiel mal aufzubekommen, man kriegt dann halt drei Bücher hingelegt, ja hier das handelt genau davon, da steht irgendwie das was du wolltest direkt auf dem Titel. Da ist das irgendwie in Kapitel 23 erwähnt und hier übrigens haben wir noch etwas, das steht in irgendeiner Form in einem Zusammenhang, aber könnte vielleicht ja auch mal interessant sein.
Und eigentlich will man genau so ja auch arbeiten. Oder auch dieses Browsing, das ist denke ich was, was man sich viel zu selten … also ich will jetzt hier keine VR-Welten haben oder so. Also es geht mir jetzt nicht darum, Second Life durch Buchregale durchzufliegen.
Hat die bayrische Staatsbibliothek ja damals auch gemacht. Fand ich auch ganz schön cool. Nutzlos aber cool.
Ja genau. Kann man machen, aber das ist jetzt nicht die Art von Adaption, die mir vorschwebt. Also ich will ja auch nur sagen, ich sehe da wirklich eine ganze Menge … oder mal anders ausgedrückt, oft merkt man bei solchen Institutionen, dass es auch eine Überforderung ist. Man hat einfach nicht das Personal mit den entsprechenden kulturellen Erlebnissen. Ich meine, wir sprechen ja auch schon so ein bisschen aus so einer, wir haben ja schon so ein bisschen die Gnade der digitalen Geburt so hinter uns gebracht und haben so ein automatisches Verständnis. Was natürlich noch nicht so weit verbreitet ist, schon gar nicht bei den älteren Generationen. Das ändert sich langsam, man möchte, dass es sich schneller ändert, aber gehört natürlich schon so ein bisschen dazu, auch so ein intuitives Verstehen dafür zu haben. Aber ich denke, dass halt, wenn man sich einfach mal auf das eigene Wissen auch an der Stelle besinnt, sehr viel zu holen ist, um diesen Prozess zu begleiten. Weil man eigentlich schon eine ganze Menge Antworten gefunden hat. Man sieht sie bloß einfach nur in diesem Analogwelt-Kontext angesiedelt.
Und glaubt, dass sie dann auch nur dafür passen. Und tatsächlich denke ich lässt sich gerade im Dialog mit Leuten, die eben die andere Welt besser kennen, eine ganze Menge umsetzen.
Das ist ein schöner Punkt, da würde ich mal ein bisschen breiter einhaken. Diese Beispiele, die ich vorhin erzählt hatte, was so an einer Auskunft alles passiert, das mit dem Tattoo und das mit dem, der da seinen Richter verklagen wollte. Das sind natürlich wirklich jetzt irgendwie so Dönekes, aber dahinter steckt ja schon immer die Praxis von so einem Beratungsgespräch, was für Informationen suchst du eigentlich wirklich? Und interessiert dich jetzt eigentlich die Domäne Kunst bei dem Tattoo oder die medizinische Domäne oder die ästhetische oder noch irgendwie ganz was anderes? Und dieses Verständnis dafür, dass die Welt eben doch verdammt kompliziert zu beschreiben ist, das ist bei Bibliothekaren einfach extrem tief verankert. Du hast da wirklich totale Nerds. Gerade so in den Fachabteilungen, das sind Leute, die sich wirklich seit Jahrzehnten halt irgendwo in ihre Gebiete vertiefen und die da wirklich Ahnung haben, wie komplex und wie kompliziert die Welt ist.
Und die immer viel komplizierter ist, als sich das ein Informatiker, der immer erst mal so den ersten …
Da machen wir eine Tabelle und dann passt das schon.
Ja, und ich denke auch, diese beiden Welten mal wirklich nachhaltig zu versöhnen, das wäre mal eine extrem sinnvolle Aufgabe. Und das versuchen wir halt relativ häufig, das zusammenzubringen. Also in meinem Referat haben wir fünf Bibliothekarinnen derzeit, sind auch alle weibliche, da hat eine neulich so schön den Begriff gesagt, menschliche APIs sind. Zwischen dem bibliothekarisch denkendem Personal und unseren Informatikern. Also die haben genug Technik-KnowHow und Verständnis, dass sie irgendwie von den Informatikern ernst genommen werden und irgendwie einigermaßen verstehen, wovon die gerade reden.
Aber sie sind People Persons, sie können auch mit den Kunden.
Sie können auch nochmal irgendwie mit normalen Menschen irgendwie versuchen, das zu übersetzen. Das ist zum Beispiel so eine der Varianten, die wir versuchen. Und wo ich persönlich, aber das ist jetzt sicherlich ein bisschen Zukunftsleserei, ein riesiges Potenzial eigentlich für Bibliothekare sehe, ist KI-Training. Weil dieser ganze Bereich der Erschließung, was wir eben gesagt hatten, mit dem Metadaten auf Objekten, das ist natürlich eigentlich auch eine richtig fies langweilig dröge doofe Arbeit. Also diese Pagenierungssequenz beispielsweise bei den Scans, die wir da hatten, wo geht es jetzt rum von arabisch zu römisch, ich meine das ist elendig zu erfassen für ein Werk. Genauso jetzt irgendwie Inhaltsverzeichnisse abtippen und zu sagen, auf welcher physischen Seite stehen die, das macht echt keinen Spaß. Und da jetzt irgendwie Normdaten raussuchen, da käme man gar nicht mehr auf den Gedanken, das noch händisch zu machen, zu gucken, welche Orte und welche Personen tauchen jetzt auf welcher Seite auf, das geht schon überhaupt nur maschinell.
Ich habe ja wirklich, weißt du ja auch schon, haben wir schon drüber gesprochen, ganz ganz rote Ohren bekommen bei deiner CRE-Folge über Machine-Learning und Deep-Learning Algorithmen. Wenn ich denn was zu sagen hätte, ich würde jetzt in Berlin mir 3-4 Koryphäen im Bereich Machine-Learning einkaufen, würde mich mit denen gerne ein Jahr einschließen und mal gucken, welche der klassischen Bibliothekserschließungsmechanismen man eigentlich hier und heute schon mit Deep-Learning Algorithmen schon relativ gut in den Griff bekommen könnte. Und dann wird man nämlich dazu kommen, dass man so, wie es immer so ist, 70-80% des Materials kriegt man gut abgefrühstückt und dann fängt das Grauen an, bei den fehlenden 20%. Und Bibliotheken haben dann eben schon, und ich denke auch zurecht, den Anspruch, naja man will schon an die 100% rankommen, weil das ist unser Missionstatement, exakt sein. Und dann eben nicht irgendwie Pi mal Daumen und Unschärfe drin haben. Und hier kommen dann glaube ich diese besonderen Skills von Bibliothekaren rein, zu sagen, quasi auf die Ergebnisse der Deep-Learning Algorithmen zu gucken und zu sagen, ja ich verstehe schon, warum ihr das da reinklassifiziert habt, aber es ist falsch aus dem und dem Grund.
Das heißt also ich glaube, es könnten perfekte Trainer sein für KIs. Und da müsste man vielleicht mal ein bisschen Geld drauf werfen. Aber man hat auch immer so viel anderes zu tun. Aber ich glaube nicht, perspektivisch werden wir die, gerade wenn man so in Begriffen wie BigData rechnet, die ganze Erschließungsebene, das werden wir nicht mehr händisch weitermachen können. Das wird sich irgendwann überlebt haben dieses Modell. Und das soll auf gar keinen Fall die Arbeit entwerten, die die tausenden Kolleginnen und Kollege all die letzen Jahrhunderte gemacht haben. Aber in Zukunft glaube ich sind das Aufgaben, die doch eher durch KIs zu lösen sind. Aber die müssen wir trainieren, denen müssen wir das Richtige beibringen, denen müssen wir auch die richtigen Grundsätze beibringen, die kann man nicht einfach machen lassen. Und das ist glaube ich so eine der zukünftigen Kernaufgaben von Bibliothekarinnen und Bibliotheken. Damit müssen wir jetzt anfangen, denn ansonsten werden die ganzen Algorithmen wieder von denen entwickelt, die eine ganz andere Agenda haben.
Naja ich denke, es gibt auch sicherlich einen gewissen Bedarf für so einen Dompteur im digitalen Zirkus. Also man hat es da halt mit allerlei dynamischen Bewegungen zu tun und natürlich ist gerade dieses Versprechen der künstlichen Intelligenz sehr weitgehend. Aber man sieht ja heute, wie es jetzt in zunehmendem Maße gelingt, auf Basis von komplexen Datenlagen, sagen wir mal so was wie ich fahre ein Auto automatisch oder ich verstehe was jemand sagt, bis hin zu Computer können sich mal eben so eine komplette Sprache dadurch anlernen, indem sie sich halt einfach mal Wörterbücher reinknallen bis zum Getno und dann entsprechend Texte lesen und das ohne selber vorher zu wissen, was sie da eigentlich gerade lernen. Dass es ja absehbar ist, dass wenn man jetzt die ganze Contentflut der bibliothekarischen Archive da reinwirft und einfach mal schaut, ob es Piep macht.
Da wird mit Sicherheit so einiges rauskommen.
Da wird sich so einiges rausfühlen lassen, was vielleicht einerseits bisher auch noch überhaupt nicht klassifiziert wurde. Das ist ja sagen wir mal eigentlich schon der zweite Schritt. Eine Versprechung war ja eben dieses, da gibt es so viele Dinge zu tun, die eigentlich keinen Spaß machen bzw. die von nur so wenigen gemacht werden können, weil sie einerseits langwierig sind und andererseits eben auch viel Verständnis …
Hochspezialisiertes Wissen.
Genau, solches Wissen brauchen. Und würde man das eben kombinieren, dann hätte man an der Stelle einfach auch die Möglichkeit, das entweder breiter auszufächern oder etwas intensiver noch zu betreiben. Auf der anderen Seite stellt sich ja die Frage dann mit meinem ersten Beispiel, was könnte man denn noch sehen? Was ist denn noch in diesem vor allem erst mal in den bisherigen Archiven, aber natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch so den Archiven der Zukunft, was müsste denn das Bibliothekswesen hier eigentlich erschließen können?
Also mal wieder ein ganz praktisches Beispiel von letzter Woche. Wir haben jetzt bei uns das sogenannten Schott-Archiv aufgekauft.
Schott?
Das ist einer der bekanntesten und renommiertesten deutschen Musikverlage. Die also über viele viele Jahrzehnte, nicht ganz Jahrhunderte, aber ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, wann der gegründet worden ist, ich denke schon so 19. Jahrhundert, das komplette Verlagsarchiv. Die Hälfte davon ist nach München gegangen von dem Archiv, die andere Hälfte zu uns an die Staatsbibliothek und noch ein paar Spezialbestände noch an andere Archive, aber die können wir jetzt mal ignorieren. Und in diesem Verlagsarchiv sind dann jetzt also zum einen wirklich Noten. Also der Verlag hat im Kern mit Notenpartituren gehandelt. Wenn du also ein Konzert hast, muss jeder der Musiker irgendwie sein Notenblatt vor sich haben und die kauft man bei einem Musikverlag und einer davon ist beispielsweise Schott. Und es also so, dass dann die Komponisten Exklusivverträge haben in der Regel mit einzelnen Verlagen und der beispielsweise mit Wagner. Das heißt also, also alle Wagner-Noten gibt es also vom Schott-Verlag.
Und dieses ganze Archiv hat jetzt aber eben nicht nur Wagner, sondern auch noch tausende von anderen Komponisten bei sich mit drin. Und zwar nicht nur die Noten, sowohl handschriftlich als auch hinterher die gestochenen Fassungen, die dann hinterher gedruckt worden sind, sondern in diesem Archiv ist auch die ganze Geschäftskorrespondenz des Verlages enthalten, nämlich wie es eigentlich zum Vertragsabschluss zwischen Verlag und Komponist kam. Und das ist schon ganz spannend, da mal reinzugucken, wie lief das denn eigentlich wirklich ab? Der Leiter der Musikabteilung der BSB München, Herr Dr. Nägele, hat das wirklich schön letzte Woche mal zusammengefasst. Man kommt jetzt hin in der Wissenschaft weg von Fragestellungen so, sich immer nur die Großkupferten anzugucken und so was hat Wagner dann noch irgendwo gemacht? Sondern ein solcher Bestand ermöglicht es plötzlich mal drauf zu gucken, wie funktioniert eigentlich das Musikgeschäft insgesamt? Und zwar mit Schwerpunkt auf Geschäft.
Und dann sieht man, dass da ganz viel triviales und banales passiert. Da sieht man dann plötzlich den Brief der Mutter an den Verlag, ihr Bub sei wirklich ein ganz ganz talentierter und er bräuchte doch wirklich ein neues Bett und darum müssten sie ihm doch bitte mal das Libretto abkaufen. Und dann siehst du plötzlich auch Komponisten, die Sachen einreichen, die dann wirklich ganz frei hinschreiben, so war letzte Woche wieder in Paris bei der Aufführung von Oper XY, hier habe ich mal die fünf relevanten Melodien als Klavierpartitur. Und ich setze mich noch hin und mache noch die restlichen drei und dann ist diese Oper aber auch abgearbeitet. Das heißt also Copyfraud haben die da betrieben. Und es gab also offensichtlich eine vitale Industrie oder Gewerbe, dass also Komponisten, die es selber so ein bisschen einfacher haben wollten, sich irgendwo international in Opern gesetzt haben und dann darauf abgeleitet mit leichten Variationen Partituren … Und das muss man jetzt gar nicht musiktheoretisch erschließen, sondern das schreiben die selber rein in diese Geschäftskorrespondenz.
Ist ja auch kulturhistorisch einfach sehr wertvoll.
Exakt. Und dann kommst du auch dazu, womit haben die wie viel Geld gemacht? Wir habe nämlich auch diese Bücher, in denen die ganzen einzelnen Werke alle verzeichnet sind. Und bei jedem steht dann drauf, in welchen Auflagen die Reprints rausgegangen sind. Und dann siehst du, dass du da 10.000 Werke hast, die es nie zu einer zweiten Auflage geschafft haben. Die waren also einfach mal nicht populär. Erste Auflage war 500 Werke und die sind nie zu Ende verkauft worden, so dass man nie eine zweite Auflage brauchte. Und dann gibt es aber halt so Bestseller, wo du dann eine 20. und 30. Auflage hast. Und auch darüber könnte man eine entsprechende Analyse machen, wie hat sich also quasi Musikpopularität eigentlich entwickelt.
Und wer war in der Top 100 1845.
Ganz genau. Und was waren dann auch so Kriterien, eine weitere wirklich sehr spannende Quelle von diesem Archiv ist, die hatten halt auch eine interne Qualitätskontrolle, wo sie also dann eben Musikwissenschaftler und Experten haben, die eingeschätzt haben, was taugt eigentlich diese Komposition, die uns hier angeboten wird. Und auch die sind dann offensichtlich sehr amüsant zu lesen, weil dann also gesagt wird, formal völlig ungenügend. So die Melodie in den ersten fünf Takten ist ganz reizend, aber danach passiert nicht mehr viel, abgelehnt. Das ist also auch, was wiederum sehr normativ ist, wie wechselt sich auch dann so Geschmack, was irgendwie Verkaufbarkeit angeht. Also super. Aber all das siehst du aber nicht, wenn du immer nur auf Wagner guckst. Und dann irgendwie darauf schaust, was hat jetzt Wagner irgendwie gemacht. Sondern BigData ist so ein ausgelutschtes Schlagwort, aber einfach mal der breite Blick auf ein großes Corpus, auf eine große Sammlung. Die also als Sammlung an und für sich dann ein gutes interessantes Forschungsobjekt ist, das ist definitiv ein Thema für die Zukunft.
Ja und an der Stelle können dann diese Machine-Learning Systeme dahingehend unterstützen, dass man sagt, okay wir trainieren jetzt erst mal Systeme darauf hin, bestimmte Dinge überhaupt zu erkennen. So was weiß ich, wir haben jetzt ein großes Briefarchiv, das ist jetzt irgendwie gescannt worden, wir haben aber keine Ahnung, was da drin steht, such uns doch überhaupt erst mal die Dinger raus, wo es wahrscheinlich um Thema X geht.
Wobei Handschriften OCR so eine der nächsten Schallmauern ist, die nicht durchbrochen sind. Also da gibt es gute Ansätze und perspektivisch würde ich sowieso sagen, alles was ein Mensch kognitiv kann, kann in 20 spätestens 30 Jahren auch eine KI ganz gut. Handschriften würde ich sagen sind so in 10 Jahren dran, vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen früher.
Also allein dafür wäre es sozusagen schon sinnvoll?
Allein dafür wäre es schon sinnvoll. Und was man auch nicht vergessen darf, wenn es beim Training von KIs geht, wir haben ja sogar Ground Truth in den Bibliotheken bis zum Abwinken. Wir haben das ja alles schon mal perfekt erschlossen.
Das heißt man hat auch quasi …
Das Lernmaterial liegt auch schon da.
… man kann sagen, wer das nicht versteht, im Machine-Learning Bereich ist es sagen wir mal vor allem dann eben einfach, alles zu lösen, indem man weiß, okay wir können der Maschine wahres und unwahres füttern und immer auch genau diese Information mit dazugeben. Das ist das, was du als richtig erkennen sollst und das ist es alles nicht. Und allein darauf können einfach diese Algorithmen eine Systematik sich selbst entwickeln, mit der man dann einfach beliebigen Daten dann quasi genau diese Antwort abverlangen kann. Gehörst du dazu oder nicht. Und mit einer beunruhigend hohen, teilweise erschreckend hohen Sicherheit, wenn denn nur genug Daten über einen längeren Zeitraum reingefüttert wurden.
Genau. Und das ist halt etwas, was keine Firma da draußen hat und leisten kann. Die können sich das überhaupt nicht leisten, jetzt Jahrzehnte lang Bibliothekare irgendwo hinzusetzen und Inhaltsverzeichnisse abzutippen oder irgendwie eine Sacherschließung zu machen. Weil die müssen halt am Markt irgendwie agieren und das bekommen sie eigentlich nicht bezahlt so. Aber Bibliotheken als eben dann auch gesamtgesellschaftliche Verantwortung und auch immer mit öffentlichen Geldern finanziert, die haben sich das eben Jahrhunderte lang geleistet. Und das ist letztendlich jetzt also ein Kapital was dort liegt, was also jetzt gerade für diese KI-Geschichten so unglaublich gut verwertbar wäre. Also wenn ich jetzt KI-Forscher wäre …
Das ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht schon eine Bringschuld oder?
Ja.
Jetzt sitzt der auf den Daten.
Naja die Daten sind da nur … also im Moment scheint es irgendwie spannender zu sein, sich irgendwie um YouTube-Videos zu kümmern und auf reine Bilder zu gehen. So die aktuellen Trends in Sachen KI gehen ja doch sehr stark in Richtung Video- und Bilderkennung. Und so auf Texten passiert, finde ich, zu wenig. Und da wäre also sicherlich gerade bei Bibliotheken extrem viel zu holen.
Warum ist das Bild so interessant? Weil da noch so wenig geleistet wurde bisher?
Vielleicht, Texte sind halt per se schon immer durchsuchbar und da hat man vielleicht schneller so diese good enough-Ebene erreicht. Wenn ich irgendeinen Volltext habe, irgendwas finde ich da schon mit einer Suche über alles. Ob ich dann auch noch so in die Tiefe analysiere, das ist dann eher so ein AddOn.
Aber ich meine gerade bei Filmen wäre genau dieser Ansatz der künstlichen Intelligenz des Machine-Learning noch sehr viel interessanter. Weil ich meine das Analysieren von Videomaterial ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht noch schwieriger, als das Analysieren von Buchtexten. Also so gescannte Wörter etc., also da weiß man ja sofort, worum es geht. Oder man weiß zumindest was da gesagt wird. Man muss halt die Sprache können, man muss irgendwie die Semantik der Sprache haben, aber das sind ja zumindest ansatzweise gelöste Probleme. Während dieses reine, ich schau mir jetzt mal mit einer Maschine einen Film an und danach weiß die Maschine worum es in diesem Film ging und was in welcher Sekunde an welcher Stelle zu sehen war, das sind ja Dinge, die wir jetzt auch langsam sehen. Da gibt es ja dieses schöne Beispiel der Katzenvideos. Dass man sich halt einfach mal so YouTube durchgenudelt hat und dann gab es danach eine Datei, wo drin stand, ja in diesem YouTube-Film an Minute 1:37 rechts oben Katze.
Und wenn man halt genauso herangeht, dann kann man natürlich Schauspielererkennung etc. bis hin vielleicht eben auch zu Handlungselementen irgendwann erkennen. Ja und dann hätte man ja Dual-use. Ich meine hätte man die Entwicklung, die man da reinsteckt, dann eben auch wunderbar schon mal geschaffen, um sie auch auf andere Ziele anzusetzen. Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, das ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, dass man sich jetzt auf Video konzentriert und man könnte ja doch hier mit dem selben Argument kommen. Weil wer hat schon die Zeit, sich alle Filme anzuschauen. Aber sich mal wirklich alle Filme mal anzuschauen mit dem Computer, das wird ja ein richtiger Spaß.
Dass das auch Sinn macht, ist glaube ich klar. Ist jetzt glaube ich nicht so ganz primäres Bibliotheksthema. Also mit Audio und Video haben es Bibliotheken dann traditionell doch eher nicht so, muss man sagen.
Ja gut, aber es fängt ja nun an, dass das Wissen der Welt im zunehmenden Maße sich eben auch in audiovisuellen Dingen niederschlägt. Ich will jetzt nicht mit Podcast kommen, aber natürlich das auch. Aber wenn man heute lernt, und ich meine man muss sich nur die Jugendlichen jetzt anschauen.
Jetzt verstehe ich was du meinst.
Wo ziehen sie denn diese Informationen her? Also die Tutorials, die Instructions etc., auch das ganze nachgeäffte, das vorgelebte kulturelle Leben bildet sich in zunehmenden Maße über audiovisuelle Medien ab. Was wir vorher noch in unserer Umgebung gelernt haben, sind teilweise Fähigkeiten, die irgendwo herkommen.
Okay. Also ich fasse das nochmal zusammen. Die These wäre, dass also quasi die nächste Evolutionsstufe der Menschheit in Bezug auf Informationsorganisation und vor allen Dingen Informationsvermittlung nach der Wikipedia ist eigentlich YouTube, als quasi nachte Instanz, wo man vor allen Dingen angewandtes Wissen irgendwo reproduzieren und sich aneignen kann. Und als solches wäre es der Auftrag der Bibliotheken, sich jetzt gerade darauf mal auch mit zu konzentrieren. Das ist eine interessante These.
Ja genau. Ich meine so Mentos und die Cola, was ist denn sozusagen das ultimative Wesen. Und wir sehen ja auch ähnliche Projekte auch schon so in der Verschlagwortung der gesamten Memetik dieses Internets. Also solche Datenbanken, die ja in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch lustige Projekte sind, so wie know your meme, die halt einfach diese ganzen Meme festhalten. Die haben ja schon einen kulturhistorischen Auftrag an der Stelle, den sie dort erfüllen. Weil man dann eben über solche Aufzeichnungen auch dieses Problem des, das ganze Internet erschlägt mich mit seinen Informationen, was ist denn hier bitte wahr, was ist denn hier bitte überhaupt noch das Original? In welcher Verkettung stehen diese ganzen Berichte, die ich hier sehe? Wie ist auch sagen wir mal eine chronologische Einordnung zu machen? Allein schon als Recherchebasis, um Fakenews zu bekämpfen.
Ja vielleicht mal kurz gedacht. Aber dann eben auch so, was passiert denn da jetzt eigentlich gerade kulturwissenschaftlich in einem großen Raum? Wer kann mir denn da bitte mal Orientierung geben?
Also darüber denke ich in den letzten Monaten, seit Trump, wie wahrscheinlich viele da draußen, auch verstärkt nach. Also was könnte die Rolle von Bibliotheken gerade jetzt auch in so einem Kontext von Fakenews beispielsweise sein? Haben Bibliotheken irgendwas anzubieten? Irgendeinen Framework, irgendeinen Ansatz, irgendein Paradigma, an dem man sich irgendwie orientieren kann. Gerade letzte Woche habe ich wieder gelesen, Jimmy Wales ist schon wieder am Start. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast?
Wiki Tribune heißt das Projekt glaube ich.
Wiki Tribune genau, wo er also auch versucht, quasi jetzt …
Also Jimmy Wales der Gründer des Wikipedia-Projekts.
Genau jetzt eine Plattform initialisieren will, wo halt quasi der Wahrheitsgrad von Nachrichten und journalistischen Entitäten letztendlich irgendwo bemessen wird. Er ist damit jetzt natürlich nicht der erste. Es hatten jetzt auch hier die Initiative von Facebook war es oder Google? Facebook glaube ich.
Na beide haben so ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie natürlich auch in ihrem Datenwald zwar irgendwie Dinge, auf die viel gezeigt wird, herausgebracht haben. Das war ja sagen wir mal die Stärke von Google, dass man einfach gesagt hat, Wahrheit bildet sich dadurch ab, dass viele drauf zeigen. Der Page Rank, das Relevanzkriterium. Nur diese Metrik greift offenbar nicht mehr. Weil auf einmal Leute Wege finden, wie man auch viel zeigen kann. Das war ja schon vorher immer ein endemisches Problem, hat sich jetzt aber in dieser Nachrichtenlage nochmal doppelt verschärft, weil man eben auch so dieses Überlagern von Information. Also ich möchte gerne, dass eine Information nicht wahrgenommen wird. Klar da kann man mit Zensur und Blockieren irgendwie rangehen. Hat sich aber gezeigt, ist viel billiger, einfach genug Alternativwahrheit daneben zu stellen und schon ist die Verwirrung groß. Und es fehlt halt an der Stelle eben wieder an dieser Orientierung. Und das ist ja auch ein Problem, was die Wissenschaft als solche auch hat und eigentlich auch immer zu lösen vorgegeben hat.
Weil nicht wahr, wie stelle ich denn fest, was quasi die etablierte Meinung über ein bestimmtes Thema ist? Wie kann ich denn darlegen, dass der Klimawandel sozusagen relevant ist? Ja viele Wissenschaftler sagen das. Aber in dem Moment, wo man diesen Wissenschaftlern auch wieder misstraut, sind wir denn in der Lage, aus unseren Daten, die wir gewonnen haben, auch ein belastbares Wahrheitsgerüst herzustellen, was auch vielleicht im Idealfall für Jedermann nachvollziehbar ist? Das würde ja helfen. Und ich glaube, das sind auch so die Überlegungen, die bei Google und Facebook gerade eine Rolle spielen.
Hier schließt sich jetzt halt ein bisschen der Kreis. Bibliotheken haben ja einfach jetzt mal ein Skalierungsproblem. Das heißt also bei dem was ich ganz am Anfang sagte, so diese Auswahl einer Sammlungsstrategie einer Bibliothek. Was bewahren wir, was sammeln wir und was lassen wir aber auch links und rechts liegen, weil es einfach mal nicht relevant ist. Also Bibliotheken waren ja auch immer ein Relevanzfilter. Weil die haben ja auch nicht wild einfach alles gemacht, sondern nur eine klare Auswahl getroffen. Im digitalen Bereich ist das halt einfach durch unsere klassischen Mechanismen, die wir in der Bibliothek haben, eigentlich de facto nicht mehr zu lösen. Also wir können jetzt nicht halt die – man kennt ja diese Charts, in wie vielen Tagen sich die Informationen des Internets verdoppeln. Da kommt kein Bibliothekar mehr durch. Da irgendwie eine Orientierung noch zu bringen. Das heißt also, hier würde ich dann wirklich eher wieder so eine Schleife sehen, okay wenn man so was dann auch irgendwie über KIs lösen möchte, dann wiederum Bibliothekare quasi als Trainer einsetzen dafür, was sind jetzt irgendwie Relevanz- und Selektionskriterien, die irgendwie einigermaßen funktionieren. Das wäre dann also schon wieder eher so ein Ansatz.
Ich sehe im Moment nicht ehrlich gesagt, dass das in der Bibliotheksszene hinreichend ernsthaft diskutiert wird. Und das sehe ich schon als ein strategisches Problem unserer Häuser an. Weil wie gesagt, ich glaube Bestand wird für Exotenthemen und Orchideen immer noch eine Rolle spielen, aber perspektivisch mittelfristig eigentlich nicht, sondern da wird es darum gehen, wie wir im digitalen Raum, dieser Informationsexplosion Herr werden und gerade eben dort dann auch Untrieben irgendwie uns entgegenstellen und dafür überzeugende Konzepte zu finden, das wird nicht einfach. Und eigentlich könnten Bibliotheken da eine gute Rolle spielen.
Was sind denn hoffnungsvolle Ansätze? Die wird es doch sicherlich auch geben?
Na es ist ja nicht Ales schlecht.
Naja eben niemals.
Also was zum Beispiel gut funktioniert ist wirklich, dass Bibliotheken auch als Lernort – das heißt also dieses Konzept, ich bin als Mensch leicht ablenkbar, die Prokrastination liegt überall am Wegesrand und vielleicht mach ich besser noch den Abwasch, anstatt irgendwie meine Hausarbeit zu Ende zu schreiben. Da merkt man in den letzten Jahren, es wird eigentlich immer weniger Bestand ausgeliehen in den Bibliotheken, aber die Lesesäle sind trotzdem konstant voll oder werden immer voller. Das heißt also, wir Menschen leben dann eben doch nicht im Digitalraum, zumindest noch nicht, sondern sind noch irgendwie so physisch real im dreidimensionalen unterwegs. Und da einen Ort zu haben, der mich zu einer gewissen Konzentration animiert, das ist schon mal eine gute Sache. Also als solches haben Bibliotheken auf jeden Fall schon mal einen dank ihrer schönen Lesesäle eben auch auf jeden Fall eine sehr robuste Zukunft.
Denn es gibt hier auch angestoßen durch den angloamerikanischen Bereich, aber mittlerweile auch auf breiter Ebene in Deutschland viele Debatte, wie man jetzt auch baulich darauf reagiert. Das heißt also grundsätzlich gibt es schon einen Trend im Bibliothekswesen zu sagen, okay weniger Regalmeter, die noch irgendwo in den Lesesälen stehen, das allermeiste steht sowieso im Magazin und wird hocheffizient binnen weniger Stunden irgendwie an die Theken gebracht und stattdessen gucken, wie ich diesen Lehr-/Lernraum Bibliothek noch dichter an die neuen Nutzungsgewohnheiten dran bringe. Das fängt natürlich mit gutem performantem W-Lan an. Dass Leute überhaupt erst mal schönes schnelles Netz haben. Geht aber auch zu solchen Sachen, dass man sagt, okay man definiert Gruppenarbeitsplätze, wo sich also eben nicht mehr so das klassisches „pssst“ einer Bibliothek, was also der Grundpreset eigentlich ist, gilt, sondern wo man auch mit akustischen Trennern so gearbeitet hat, dass sich mal eine Gruppe von 5-6 Leuten irgendwie hinsetzen kann und an irgendwie einem Board was entwickeln oder einen Beamer hat, wo sich alle draufschalten können und so was.
So ein bisschen mehr so ein Coworking-Gedanke auch?
Genau, so eine Infrastruktur einfach herzustellen. Wo es auch lustigerweise relativ viele Initiativen gibt, jetzt keine bei uns in Berlin, also an der Stabi ist Makerspaces beispielsweise an Bibliotheken einzurichten. Das sieht man jetzt häufiger. Also auch hier eine Infrastruktur anzubieten, wo man so als Normalsterblicher ansonsten nicht so wirklich drankommt. Und da habe ich dann halt einen 3D-Drucker und irgendwie Infrastruktur und kann dahin und irgendwie mal was entwickeln und mit was experimentieren. So das sind also auch Bestrebungen, über die viel geredet wird. Also Bibliotheken als physisch realer Ort haben glaube ich eine ziemlich gute Zukunft. Da mache ich mir relativ wenig Sorgen.
Das finde ich ein bisschen überraschend, muss ich sagen. Also ich drücke mich jetzt nicht selber so viel in Bibliotheken herum, von daher habe ich da eine schlecht informierte Basis.
Man merkt es immer dann, wenn eine Bibliothek mal geschlossen ist oder ein Lesesaal mal gerade irgendwie zumacht wegen Umbauarbeiten oder so was, dann bricht also schon die Panik los. Also wir hatten das hier in Berlin, wie heißt die neben UDL dahinten die Uni? Von der HU das Lehr- und Lernzentrum, wie auch immer, war mal geschlossen und dann wurden also unsere Lesesäle überrannt, weil die Leute also irgendwo einen Ausgleich gesucht haben, wo sie sich stattdessen irgendwie hinsetzen können. Ich hätte auch eher gedacht, dass Bibliothek – Christian Mahnke aus Göttingen hat das mal verglichen mit, wenn Bibliotheken nicht aufpassen, dann sind sie so die Kirchen der Zukunft. Das heißt also als touristische Attraktion guckt man sie sich noch gerne an, aber Gottesdienste finden da eigentlich nur noch so vor leeren Reihen statt. Also das eigentliche Arbeiten in der Bibliothek. Und man genießt das noch so als Ambiente, aber nicht mehr als wirklich ernstzunehmende Infrastruktur.
So ach die schöne Architektur.
Genau. Das scheint gerade überhaupt nicht der Fall zu sein, sondern also ganz im Gegenteil. Wie gesagt dieses, ich ziehe mich aus meiner normalen Umgebung raus und gehe an einen Ort, der mir wirklich Konzentration auferlegt, das scheint ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Um vielleicht mal den Bereich Softwareentwicklung nochmal genauer anzuschauen. Deine eigene Leistungsbeschreibung auf der Webseite ist ja auch davon die Rede, konkret mit agiler Softwareentwicklung zu arbeiten. Was verbirgt sich hinter diesem Begriff und warum ist das an dieser Stelle so wichtig?
Naja wir haben es deshalb reingenommen, um uns so ein bisschen so von dem klassischen V-Modell, wie es eigentlich so im öffentlichen Dienst vorgeschrieben ist glaube ich immer noch, überzusetzen.
V-Modell?
V-Modell sagt letztendlich, jetzt mal auf einen sehr kurzen Nenner gebracht, man hat irgendwie so ein 3-Jahres-Entwicklungsprojekt und am Anfang investiert man die ersten drei Monate, um genau irgendwie schon die Spezifikation festzulegen und dann programmiert man lange durch und dann testet man irgendwann und macht noch ein paar Änderungen und dann hat man irgendwann den Release. Und das ist also alles so ein drei Jahre währender Schlauch und währenddessen hat sich die Erde aber fünfmal weitergedreht und alles ist völlig überholt und funktioniert eigentlich nicht mehr. Und unserer Ansatz ist eigentlich eher in relativ kompakten Entwicklungs-Sprints eher voranzugehen. Das muss dann nicht immer nach Scrum sein, da haben wir also uns eine gewisse Flexibilität durchaus auch erlaubt. Auch KanBan beispielsweise spielt da eine Rolle oder auch Selbstausgedachtes probieren wir auch durchaus mal.
Also es sind auch alles so Vorgehensmodelle für Softwareentwicklung.
Ja für Softwareentwicklung, wie ich schneller Teilreleases rausgeben kann. Wie man auch irgendwie mit Betadiensten mal schon direkt auf Endnutzer arbeitet, ohne dass schon alles komplett fertig ist und ich mir währenddessen schon Feedback reinhole. Ja das soll einfach nur zeigen, wir sind da nicht so unterwegs, wie man es vielleicht so althergebracht machen würde am öffentlichen Dienst. Also a) wir entwickeln überhaupt selber. Also es wird nicht outgesourct, sondern wir machen selber Softwareentwicklung für Bibliotheken, was ich auf grundrichtig halte. Und b) halt, wir versuchen das auch auf einem möglichst moderne zeitige Art und Weise zu tun.
Für wen ist dann diese Software? Nur für die Bibliotheken selber? Oder entsteht hier auch Software, die über den Bibliotheksprozess hinaus Relevanz hat?
Also im besten Fall auch zweiteres. Es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie eine neue Oberfläche oder eine neue Suchmaschine für ein spezielles Nachweissystem für eine Sondersammlung der Staatsbibliothek machen, dann wird das schon relativ spezialisiert sein. Weil es dann vielleicht auch wirklich auf einem spezifischen Datenmodell irgendwie basiert. Aber es gibt auch durchaus Dinge, die wir von Vornherein so generisch planen, dass man sie eigentlich auch völlig abseits vom Bibliothekskontext nutzen kann. Vielleicht ein ganz passendes Beispiel dazu, eine Sache, die ich in Göttingen erfunden habe, das waren Raum-Zeit-Visualisierungen von Daten. Da gräme ich mich immer noch ein bisschen drum, dass ich das nicht konsequent genug irgendwie durchgezogen habe so. Das hätte finde ich etwas mehr Weltruhm verdient gehabt. Das lief damals unter dem Label Europeana4D. Europeana die europäische digitale Bibliothek. Und die hatten diverse Unterprojekte und eines davon waren halt wir in Göttingen in Kooperation mit der visuellen Informatik in Leipzig.
Und unser Grundgedanke war, wir wollen Daten gleichzeitig in Zeit und Raum mappen. Das war so vor sieben Jahren und da gab es eigentlich in der Richtung nichts. Es gab Google Maps und es gab Open Street Map und da konnte man eine Information auf eine Karte mappen, auch mit Informationsebenen schon. Und es gab so was wie die SIMILE-Timeline, wo man Daten innerhalb einer Zeitebene irgendwie ganz vernünftig visualisieren konnte. Und wir hatten ein Konzept erfunden, haben das dann auch publiziert, können wir mal in die Shownotes packen den Artikel, wie man beides interaktiv miteinander verbinden kann. Das heißt also, ich habe Information, sagen wir mal ein Beispieldatenset was wir hatten war Opfer rechtsradikaler Gewalt. Hatten wir aus der DBpedia sogar gezogen die Information. Und der einzelne Datenpunkt bezeichnete also den Tathergang, wo das passiert ist und wann es passiert ist. Genau die drei Informationen, die wir dafür brauchten.
Und jetzt hattest du also auf einen Blick oben deine Karte, wo du schon eine räumliche Verteilung hattest. Eine unserer Fragen war nämlich, wie verhält es sich Westdeutschland vs. die neuen Bundesländer. Und unten drunter hattest du eine Zeitleiste, wo du sehen konntest, wie haben sich eigentlich jetzt diese rechtsradikalen Anschläge irgendwie über die Zeit verändert. Und jetzt soweit so noch bekannt und der Clou war dann aber die Interaktion. Das heißt du konntest beispielsweise jetzt so eine Timerange von einem Jahr unten auf der Zeitleiste markieren und hast dann direkt gesehen, wo jetzt in diesem ausgewählten Jahr oben auf der Karte die entsprechenden Anschläge waren und dann konntest du hingehen und diese Timerange verschieben auf der Zeitleiste und dann hast du oben gesehen, wie geografisch sich Schwerpunkte gebildet oder wieder aufgelöst haben. Und umgekehrt funktioniert das genauso. Das heißt also du konntest beispielsweise dann den kompletten Osten markieren und den kompletten Westen markieren und konntest dann unten auf der Zeitleiste sehen, wann waren quasi die Peaks im Osten und wann waren die Peaks im Westen.
Und gab es eigentlich irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten oder Unterschiede? Also Korrelationen konnte man damit beispielsweise ganz gut rauskriegen in Zeit und Ort. Und das konnte man auf sehr sehr viele verschiedene Fragestellungen mappen, weil das Datenmodell dahinter, das waren einfach Triple, Datentriple halt, Zeit, Ort und halt irgendwie Event. Und wir hatten ein paar wirklich clevere Sachen, beispielsweise eine Schnittstelle an Flickr, Bilddatenbank. Bevor Yahoo das gekauft hat, war das so die relevante Bilddatenbank. Und da haben wir beispielsweise mal als Datenset eingeladen von Flickr, die hatten auch ein ganz gutes API, von der Tsunami-Katastrophe in Japan Fukushima, was dort die Leute an Bildern dazu in Flickr hochgeladen haben. Dann konntest du auf der Karte sehen, indem du unten auf dem Zeitstrahl gewandert bist, wie die Welle über Japan gegangen ist, anhand der Bilder, die die Leute dazu hochgeladen haben mit Timestamp und Ortsinformation versehen. Das war einigermaßen gruselig.
Wie auch die Bilder selber.
Wie auch die Bilder selber ja. Aber es funktionierte. Und das war eigentlich ein sehr sehr schöner, sehr generischer Ansatz. Wir haben es dann auch mit Bibliotheksdaten gefüttert natürlich. Da kam es ja eigentlich her. Also beispielsweise alle Publikationen, die wir an der SUB hatten, über Goethe vs. Schiller. Du konntest auch mehrere Datensets reinladen, bis zu vier, die dann in unterschiedlichen Farben jeweils miteinander gleichzeitig abgebildet worden sind. Und dann konntest du sehen, wann also Schiller besonders populär war und in welchen Bereichen und wann Goethe dann also irgendwo on the long Run den viel größere Longtale hätte, wo zu Lebzeiten eigentlich Schiller durchaus vom Publikationsvolumen her populärer war, zumindest phasenweise. Alle solche Abhängigkeiten hattest du da plötzlich drin. Und das haben wir noch wirklich als OpenSource veröffentlicht und es haben sich auch noch etliche dran drauf gesetzt. Also Fraunhofer hat das adaptiert für die deutsche digitale Bibliothek. Ist dann allerdings da nie so richtig dann irgendwie zur Reife gekommen.
Dann hat sich hier das MPI für Wissenschaftsgeschichte hat sich das genommen und hat da eine Visualisierung draus gebaut. Dann im DARIAH-Kontext, ein anderes Forschungsprojekt hat das weiterentwickelt. Also ich hatte dann wiedermal anderes zu tun, wie das dann immer so ist, und eigentlich hätte man das nochmal komplett wieder wegwerfen und neu implementieren müssen auf noch aktuellerer Webtechnik, damit das von der Usability her wirklich endnutzertauglich war. Das war schon ein Wissenschaftswerkzeug, so wie wir es gebaut hatten und du brauchtest eigentlich schon – du musst dir erst mal ein 30 Minuten Trainingsvideo angucken, damit du wirklich verstehst, wie funktioniert das Ganze eigentlich. Und wenn man nochmal so ein Vierteljahr investiert hätte, hätte man es wirklich so machen können, dass es auf Spiegel Online gut funktioniert hätte, sagen wir mal. Mittlerweile gibt es solche Sachen.
Genau, den Brückenschlag wollte ich gerade machen. Weil mich erinnert das natürlich schon sehr an diesen Trend des Datenjournalismus, den wir jetzt sehen. Weil jetzt solche Projektteams und solche Datenvisualisierung und Recherchen ja in zunehmendem Maße eben aus diesem Bereich heraus auch kommen. Und damit sind wir auch wieder am Anschluss an unseren Diskussionspunkt vorher, so diese Wahrheitsfindung, die auf einmal damit verknüpft ist.
Ja. Also genau Datenvisualisierung ist finde ich auch spannend für Bibliotheken. Auch und gerade in Bezug darauf, was ich vorhin sagte, die ganze Sammlung als Untersuchungsgegenstand. Da kann ich dann nämlich schon ganz Interessante Visualisierung auch drauflegen. Also jetzt in dem Schott-Projekt, was ich vorhin erwähnt hatte, das mit dem Verlagsarchiv, da ist ein Arbeitspaket, das wir dezidiert da in den DFG-Antrag reingeschrieben haben. Wirklich auch Datenvisualisierung, um eben sagen zu können, wie haben sich jetzt hier Klavierpartituren verhalten im Vergleich zu was weiß ich. Und dann halt entsprechende Charts mit D3JS, was ja sogar das gängige Framework ist, das wollen wir dann zum ersten Mal auch selber mal vernünftig ausprobieren darauf, da so was zu fahren. Das finde ich schon sehr sinnvoll. Wer da ziemlich weit ist sind die in Potsdam. Die haben auch da auf den Datenbeständen von der deutschen digitalen Bibliothek schon mal so ein paar proof of concept Visualisierungen gemacht.
Das ist genauso eine Ebene, wo ich denke, wo ich vorhin gesagt habe, so die ästhetische visuelle Komponente von Bibliotheken im digitalen Bereich. Damit meine ich eben jetzt nicht Stuck am Bau und irgendwie Lichtschacht, sondern zum Beispiel Datenvisualisierung. Wir haben tolle Daten, wir könnten mal hingehen, damit einfach mal ein paar dann auch wirklich in den Massengeschmack reichende Konzepte zu erfinden.
Ja so Datenarchitektur voranbringen.
Ja.
Was haben wir noch nicht behandelt? Gibt es noch ein letztes Wort?
Kommt zu Bibliotheken, es ist super da.
Nein ernsthaft. Also ich bin ja totaler Quereinsteiger, das werden mir meine bibliothekarischen Kollegen jetzt wahrscheinlich auch um die Ohren hauen, die sich das jetzt anhören so, was da alles an Unschärfen und Fehlinformationen drin war, ich bin eigentlich Sozialwissenschaftler, der als Quereinsteiger halt da in der Bibliothek gelandet ist.
Ein Wunsch?
Tja wer ist kein Quereinsteiger?
Und würde aber im Nachhinein sagen, so im Bezug auf meine Berufswahl war das eine der besten Entscheidungen, die ich überhaupt irgendwie jemals getroffen habe. Weil ich war immer sehr sprunghaft in meinen Interessen. Mich haben immer sehr sehr unterschiedliche Sachen interessiert. Und an einer Bibliothek habe ich quasi die Möglichkeit, mich jedes Vierteljahr mit einem anderen Wissenschaftsfachgebiet zu beschäftigen. Jetzt war es ein Jahr lang viel mit Ostasien. Jetzt machen wir demnächst wieder Karten und dann machen wir wieder Recht. Und die ticken halt alle so lustig anders. Die haben halt so ihre ganz eigene Denke und ihre eigene Domäne. Und in der Bibliothek hat man einfach mal die Flexibilität, mit denen alle lustigen Erfahrungen zu machen und viele unterschiedliche Sachen zu lernen. Und dabei ist man auch noch – und das meine ich jetzt echt ernst – man ist bei den Guten. Mein Kollege Jens Ludwig hat gerade vor zwei Wochen gesagt, so einer der Gründe, warum er da gerne bei einer Bibliothek ist, da kann er sich sicher sein, er richtet keinen Schaden an. Wer kann das schon heutzutage.
Wer kann das von sich behaupten?
Wer kann das von sich behaupten. Wir haben eben eine Agenda, die eigentlich durch und durch gut ist. Die funktioniert irgendwie seit Jahrhunderten nachweisbar vernünftig. Es spricht wenig dafür, dass das anders wird. Ich komme aus den Sozialwissenschaften SoWi Fakultät der Uni Göttingen. Was ein echtes Haifischbecken war. Und dann kam ich wirklich zur SUB Göttingen und dachte nur, meine Güte seid ihr alles Gutmenschen. Das ist ja so angenehm hier. Und das ist jetzt an der Stabi ganz genauso. Die Leute gucken mich immer etwas schräg an, wenn ich ihnen das so erzähle. Weil natürlich klar hat man Differenzen und ja es gibt irgendwie Machtspielchen und so, aber das ist im Vergleich zu dem, was da draußen ansonsten so passiert, sowohl im Wissenschaftsbereich und von der freien Wirtschaft fange ich gar nicht an, ist das alles so harmlos.
Alles weiße Krieger.
Die meinen es alle so gut eigentlich. Und es geht nur darum, welche der Strategien jetzt irgendwie denn nur die richtige ist. Aber eigentlich wolle alle schon das Richtige und das Gute. Und von daher, Informatiker dieser Welt bewerbt euch bitte bei Bibliotheken, wenn ihr ausgebrannt seid bei euren Startupbuden und irgendwie kein Bock auf Flipper habt.
Mediengestalter dieser Welt.
Mediengestalter, Datenvisualisierer. Und denkt mal dran, ihr müsst auch irgendwann mal eine Familie gründen und dann ist so ein Job im öffentlichen Dienst auch eine ganz gute Sache, auch wenn man da ein bisschen weniger verdient. Aber die Lebensqualität, an einer Bibliothek zu arbeiten, finde ich ist super. Also Leute kommt zu uns.
Ralf vielen Dank.
Bitte bitte.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören wie immer hier bei Forschergeist. Ich hoffe, ihr seid bald auch bei der nächsten Ausgabe wieder mit dabei. Bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.